Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast wie ich ein Buch gelesen und mir fällt auf, du hast es nicht physisch dabei, du hast nur Notizen.
Ja, denn dieses Buch ist so frisch, dass man nur das PDF uns schicken konnte.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Und wir haben noch kein Rezensionsexemplar oder konnten es noch nicht im Laden kaufen. Jetzt aber, wo wir gerade das hier veröffentlichen, kann man das Buch kaufen. Es stammt von der Taz-Journalistin Ulrike Herrmann. Geld als Waffe ist der Titel. Wir haben von ihr schon das Ende des Kapitalismus gelesen. Sie ist ja eine De-Growth-Anhängerin, sagt also, wenn wir den Klimawandel wirksam bekämpfen wollen, dann müssen wir schrumpfen. Das geht nicht mit erneuerbaren Technologien nur, sondern wir müssen radikal schrumpfen. Eigentlich auf so einen Stand, wenn wir jetzt von Deutschland sprechen, der 70er Jahre, auf den müssen wir zurück. Jetzt aber ist interessanterweise in ihrem neuen Buch gar nichts davon zu lesen, denn man könnte ja auch über Geld als Waffe gegen die Klimakatastrophe nachdenken. Nein, worum es hier geht, ist Geld als Waffe. Wie wird das also künftig sein mit den geopolitischen Konflikten? Wird China angreifen? Wird Russland angreifen? Was hat Europa hier zu tun? Europa jedenfalls sehen wir hier als einen rein passiven Akteur beschrieben, der jetzt Weltgeschichte erst einmal erleidet durch die großen, starken Männer. Und wir werden viele, viele Widersprüche, so denke ich, in diesem Buch finden.
Okay, dann droht ja Schlimmes, denn ich rekapituliere, was du jetzt gesagt hast. Bei dem letzten Buch wollte sie uns in die Steinzeit zurücksparen und wir sagten, da haben wir gar keine Lust drauf. Und jetzt sagt sie, doch, doch, wir müssen doch Geld ausgeben für Waffen.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen, also das finde ich ebenso interessant jetzt an diesem Buch, denn Ulrike Herrmann ist ja eine linke Journalistin, die kennen wir. Sie sitzt in Talkshows und bietet dann so rechten Positionen Paroli, die sagen, wir brauchen jetzt aber unbedingt Schuldenbremse und diese Heizungshammer, das muss mal aufhören. Und dann kommt Ulrike Herrmann und hat meist die richtigen Argumente dagegen parat, bekommt ja dafür dann auch in den sozialen Medien Applaus und auch von uns. Aber jetzt hat sie hier so ein ganzes Buch ausgearbeitet, mit dem sie sich eigentlich ganz undockt an Carlo Massalla, Sönke Neizl, die ja auch hier häufig zitiert werden. Das heißt, sie ist jetzt ganz eigentlich auch auf dieser Militärdoktrin, versucht es jetzt aber nochmal ökonomisch zu unterfüttern, wenngleich ich auch sagen würde, das gelingt eigentlich nicht. Also das Versprechen des Titels ist das eine, ob es eingelöst wird, ist was anderes. Zumal hier wir bei aller Stringenz, die diese Erzählung an den Tag legt, die Ulrike Herrmann uns hier vorlegt, doch eigentlich mit sehr vielen Leerstellen zu tun haben, bei denen wir uns fragen müssen, was ist da los? Aber da wir hier so ein großes Reich der Spekulation betreten, ist es doch sehr typisch eigentlich für die Diskurse, die wir seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine erleben.
Ja, also dann versuche ich nochmal zu retten, denn ich bin eigentlich voller Vorfreude. Immerhin haben wir hier Bücher gelesen zum Thema, wie der IWF in eine Waffe verwandelt wurde oder wie die ganze Geoökonomie plötzlich Instrumente weaponized, wie man im Englischen sagt. Und sie wird ja wohl an diese Diskurse anschließen, sodass wir unsere eigene Lektüre, Erlebnisse, die wir da bisher hatten, einfach fortentwickeln.
Ja, wir haben den Vorteil, wir sind doch in Bilder und deshalb sollten wir uns das genau vor diesem Hintergrund ansehen. Und sicherlich muss man ja immer bei einem Sachbuch sehen, inwieweit es von der Aktualität eingeholt oder heimgesucht wird. Auch da, denke ich, ist es ganz interessant, da wir jetzt gerade einen westlichen Krieg erleben, also von USA und Israel gegen den Iran, müssen wir das natürlich auch vor dem Hintergrund lesen und diskutieren. Was heißt das eigentlich? Und möglicherweise ist diese, ja, eigentlich nur reagierende Stellung des Westens, die Ulrike Herrmann hier nahelegt, eine, die nicht ganz mit der Realität zusammengeht.
Also wir hören schon, du bist offensiv kritisch.
Ich sage, das ist ein ziemlich gefährliches und auch falsches Buch.
Ich täusche hier natürlich noch ein bisschen Sparingspartner fürs Vorgespräch vor, bevor ich gleich auch einsteige in die Texte Exegese. Und ich denke, wir sind bereit dafür.
Wir sind bereit. Und wie gesagt, das ist ja also der zweite Teil des Salons jetzt hier. Wir haben schon den ersten Teil veröffentlicht. Da haben wir gesprochen über dieses herrliche Buch von Bibi. Bibi's Beauty Palace mit einer neuen Personality und haben unsere Empfehlungen gegeben. Jetzt also im zweiten Teil geht es dann nur und ausführlich um das Buch Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann. Über zwei Stunden diskutieren wir darüber. Viel Spaß jetzt erstmal mit Ulrike Herrmann.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Hast du schon mal Geld als Waffe benutzt?
Eher nicht, es geht bei mir um Komfort.
Das finde ich sehr gut. Ich nutze mein Geld typischerweise auch für Komfort. Aber ich dachte mir so ein bisschen, der Untertitel ist vielleicht entscheidender hier, wie die Wirtschaft über Krieg und Frieden entscheidet. Ja. Du podcastest ja nun seit Jahren in Wohlstand für alle zu dem Argument, die Wirtschaft, im Sinne wie Marx nicht der Kapitalist, sondern das Kapital selbst, ist ein entscheidender Protagonist.
Ja.
Das heißt, dieses Buch ist ziemlich auf deine Wellenlänge eigentlich.
Nein. Denn erstmal gibt es ja eine sehr große Debatte darüber, ob wir überhaupt die Kriege dem Kapital zu verdanken haben. Also es gibt eine leninistische Lesart, die da sehr von ausgeht. Ja, also die sagt, das ist dann, wenn sich gerade so ein Monopolkapitalismus herausbildet, dann häufig so, dass der irgendwann kriegerisch wird, also dass die Begehrlichkeiten größer wird oder auch in so einem Konkurrenzdruck heraus. Das ist die eine Lesart. Dann gibt es natürlich auch so eine Lesart, die sagt, ja, es ist einfach die mächtige Rüstungsindustrie, der militärisch-industrielle Komplex, der dafür sorgt, dass Kriege sich lohnen. Aber dann gibt es natürlich auch eine Richtung in der marxistischen Linie, die sagt, nein, es sind erst einmal Staatsinteressen. Die sind natürlich auch gekoppelt an die Wirtschaft, wie wir immer wieder sehen. Aber letztendlich entscheiden die Staaten darüber, dass sie Krieg haben wollen. Jemand wie Eric Hobsbawm, ein britischer Historiker, hat ja in seinem Buch über den Beginn des ersten Weltkrieges und über den ersten Weltkrieg dann ja auch geschrieben, es war eigentlich eine Situation, in der selbst das Großkapital in Deutschland sagte, wir wollen den Krieg nicht. Das heißt, das ist also immer die Frage, wer ist eigentlich dafür verantwortlich, etwas, was wir hier so einfach nicht klären können. Aber das ist natürlich ein Zusammenhang, gibt es klar. Der Zusammenhang, der jetzt hier von Ulrike Herrmann hergestellt wird, ist ja folgender, wenn es Ländern wirtschaftlich schlecht geht oder sie sich nicht so entwickeln, wie sie sich eigentlich hätten entwickeln können oder wollen, dann neigen die Akteure in autokratisch geführten Staaten dazu, zu kriegerischen Mitteln zu greifen. Deshalb riff Putin die Ukraine an und wird er weitere Begehrlichkeiten haben, um Kriege zu verlängern, um neue Kriege anzuzetteln. Und deshalb, so prognostiziert sie, ist es auch nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass China Taiwan angreift und weitere hegemoniale Bestrebungen an den Tag legt. Dieses Buch ist ja also auf der These gegründet, dass man, wenn es wirtschaftliche Schwächen gibt, von diesen abzulenken sucht, dadurch, dass man angreift, dass man also vom innenpolitischen Dilemma ablenkt, um nach draußen sich zu richten und äußere Feinde aufzustellen. Das ist ja erst mal sehr schlicht gedacht und auch etwas, was man so nachvollziehen kann. Ich würde aber sagen, dieses Buch hat so viele Widersprüche. Es ist für mich eines der schlechtesten Bücher, die wir hier im Salon je gelesen haben. Ich bin ziemlich entsetzt darüber, weil es in einem Brustton der Überzeugung alles vorgetragen wird. Dass man denkt, ja genau, innerhalb dieser Logik mag das vielleicht sehr lange Sinn ergeben. Aber wenn man mal so ein paar andere Aspekte mit aufnimmt, außerhalb der Ulrike Herrmann Welt, dann können wir sehen, da passt doch einiges nicht zusammen. Und ich glaube, was wir hier vorfinden, ist ganz ähnlich wie das Buch, das wir schon von Ulrike Herrmann besprochen haben, nämlich Das Ende des Kapitalismus, dass sie auch sehr gut ist, ein sehr, sehr festes Weltbild zu haben und aus dieser Logik heraus sehr stichhaltig zu argumentieren. Aber man kann sich dann das Weltbild ja mal als solches ansehen. Und das haben wir ja damals gemacht und gesagt, naja, vielleicht müssen wir doch nicht ins Jahr 1974 zurück, um die Welt zu retten.
Genau. Um den letzten Punkt aufzugreifen, ich habe, wie ein Wunder, nichts gegen feste Weltbilder, die auch im Gespräch verteidigt werden, solange sie nachvollziehbare Theoriegerüste mit sich führen. Und genau das vermisse ich hier. Und dadurch ist das Buch, das seinem Untertitel nach viel verspricht, tatsächlich finde ich auch eins der schwächsten, aber gar nicht so sehr, weil ich es jetzt uninteressant finde oder so, sondern weil es einfach so ein Eier, okay, und so stimmt, ja, keine Ahnung. Könnte sein. Genau, könnte sein. Denn das Prinzip, Ulrike Herrmann gut zu finden, weil sie in einer Landsendung aus der Hüfte geschossen gegen einen CDU mit Departierenden sagt, sie haben ja nichts anzubieten. Und eigentlich müsste man mal darüber nachdenken. Da kann man einfach sagen, ja, das stimmt. Aber die Entfaltung davon ist dann doch nochmal eine andere. Denn dass irgendwer gar kein Angebot hat, so wie du es ja auch der CDU unterstellst, die aber regiert, das lädt nun sehr viele ein, eine Fundamentalkritik zu machen. Aber das Gegenangebot, das ist dann doch auf einer zweiten Ebene eine eigene Herausforderung. Und auf dieser Ebene kommen wir hier nicht.
Man sieht schnell gut aus, neben Christian Lindemann willst du uns damit auch sagen.
Genau, genau, genau, genauso.
Nee, Carsten heißt er doch, oder?
Carsten Lindemann, ja. Aber wir können ja auch Christian nennen, weil am Ende ist eh egal.
Sag aber doch mal was zu diesem Titel. Was hast du gedacht, als du ein Buchtitel lesen konntest mit Geld als Waffe? Worum es geht?
Also es gibt zwei Punkte, die werde ich auch gleich markieren. Da kann man dann ins Detail gehen. Geld als Waffe interessiert mich wahnsinnig, weil Kriege werden, das wissen wir aus den Nachrichten, von Protagonisten angezettelt. Trump gibt ein Befehl, Kamini ist tot. Und was wir ja immer wieder feststellen ist, neben diesen normativen Strukturen, ein Politiker trifft eine Entscheidung, damit wird Recht bindend und Leute müssen halt machen, was befohlen ist. Gibt es eine kognitive Ebene? Was ist möglich? Was kann man lernen? Kriegsvorschritte? Wir haben das Zusammenfallen von beiden immer wieder, wenn wir sagen, okay, der Angriffsbefehl ist gegeben, damit ist die politische Dimension klar. Und eine Woche später kriegen wir Aufklärung darüber, dass gar nicht mehr mit Panzern gekämpft wird, sondern mit Drohnen, weil es gab kognitive Lernerfolge, dass es mit Drohnen irgendwie besser funktioniert. Und es ist auch sehr viel profitabler, mit einer 10.000 Euro Drohne auf einen 8 Millionen Panzer zu schießen. So und damit haben wir soziologisch ein hochinteressantes Phänomen, dass wir nämlich eine normative Struktur haben, die aber kognitiv entfaltet wird. Da könnte man jetzt unendlich viel drüber sagen, aber ich glaube, es ist im Groben so klar geworden. Und Geld zählt in dieses Kognitive. Ein Profitinteresse, ja, da gibt es normative Schranken. Das nennen wir dann irgendwie hier, keine Ahnung. Es gibt verschiedene Gesetzesbrüche, da muss man sich dran halten. Aber typischerweise, das ist ja die Triebfehler des Kapitalismus, darf man einfach lernen, was profitabel ist. Und solange man niemand groß auf die Füße tritt, ist einfach klar so. Ich muss jetzt nicht erst eine Mehrheit organisieren, die Belegschaft überzeugen oder sonstige normativen, juristisch eingehegten politischen Prozesse ablaufen, sondern ich stelle einfach fest, ich habe mal wieder einen Kundeninteresse getroffen, also zack. So und hier Geld als Waffe. Also Geld, die kognitive Kraft von Geld mischt sich da ein Waffe, wo wir einen Krieg, immer Protagonisten, Politik, Weltlage, was auch immer. So von daher ist das natürlich super vielversprechend, so einen Buchtitel zu haben, aber es wird auch relativ schnell klar, dass wir hier nicht nur auf ein, finde ich, raffiniertes Denkbeutel treffen, sondern wir kommen gar nicht zu irgendeiner Theorie, weil schon im Einstieg, sie nennt Boris Johnson und Herfried Münkler, die im 20-Jahres-Rhythmus, also Münkler wohl schon 2002, sagt, der zwischenstaatliche Krieg ist ein historisches Auslaufmodell. Boris Johnson sagt 2021, Panzerschlachten auf europäischen Boden sind passé. Das bedeutet ja, sie macht auf jeden Fall eine Beobachtung und sie versucht, die jetzt irgendwo festzubinden, nur wir sind doch jetzt aufgeklärt genug, um zu sagen, nee, diese Kriege hat es immer gegeben. Das Einzige, was den Ukraine Krieg von den bisherigen unterscheidet, ist, dass er uns passiert ist. Wer dem Tooze sagt, wir haben ihn uns nicht ausgesucht, sondern typischerweise greifen wir doch den Iran an. Typischerweise lassen wir doch Gaza geschehen. Typischerweise ist uns doch die Westsahara egal und nicht umgedreht. So und jetzt kam das halt mal zurück. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, und darüber haben wir ja oft geredet, dass Putin als nächstes jetzt das Baltikum, dann Polen und dann Deutschland und wir dann alle Russisch sprechen.
Ja.
So, aber das steckt halt hier drin.
Das steckt hier sehr drin und vielleicht sprechen wir dann Russisch und Chinesisch. Also die China-Kapitel sind noch mal sehr viel schwächer als die Russland-Kapitel, denn da sind wir so stark im Reich der Spekulation, dass ich denke, ja, ich kann das auch mal aufschreiben, wie das möglicherweise sein könnte. Ich kann auch noch Chat-GPT dazu befragen, male mir immer drei mögliche Szenarien oder auch drei unmögliche aus und dann bekomme ich das. Wenn ich den Titel Geld als Waffe lese, dann denke ich an Swift, dann denke ich an die Dollarisierung oder befürchtete End-Dollarisierung, dann denke ich an die Rolle der Zentralbanken, dann denke ich an Sanktionen. Ich denke an das sehr gute Buch über Sanktionen von Nicolas Mulder. All das finden wir gar nicht oder nur mal am Rande in diesem Text. Und stattdessen bekommen wir hier einzelne Kapitel mit so einer Waffenkunde. Was gibt es jetzt gerade?
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, du läufst auf die Pointe raus, dass wir dieses Buch zu all den Sachen, die du aufgezählt hast, Sanktionsregime, Interventionen auf die Wiesenmärkten, Rohstoffembargos, Technologiemonopole, strategische Korruption, gezielte Finanzhilfe, Zölle, das haben wir ja gelesen. Geoökonomie.
Geoökonomie ist das. Also wir haben eigentlich das, was wir gelesen haben oder mitbekommen haben. Maurice Höfgen hat ja auch ein Buch geschrieben über Inflation und Sanktionen, diesen Wirtschaftskrieg. Wir haben Nikolaus Mulder, wir haben Branko Milanović gelesen, wir haben Milan Babic. Wir haben diese Werke, die hier nicht vorkommen, beziehungsweise auch ein Denken, das nicht vorkommt bei Ulrike Herrmann. Stattdessen erzählt sie uns, um so ein bisschen die Struktur klar zu machen, erst mal welche möglichen Szenarien sie sieht. Sie bezieht sich dabei sehr häufig auf die auf die üblichen Verdächtigen. Das sind Carlo Massalla und Sönke Neitzel, also möglicherweise der letzte Sommer in Frieden und so weiter. Dann schildert sie uns so eine kurze Entwicklungsgeschichte Russlands mit Putin dann an der Macht und was Putin in seiner Amtszeit alles getrieben hat. Dabei wird immer so vieles miteinander vermischt. Einmal so der privat-autoritäre Putin zur Familie und seiner Frau, der KGB-Mann Putin, dann aber auch so ein bisschen die Oligarchen. Dann bekommen wir noch mal so ein kleines Ukraine-Kapitel serviert, um dann eine chinesische Entwicklungsgeschichte, eine Wirtschaftsgeschichte zu bekommen, die auch, sagen wir, sehr ausgesucht ist, um dann nachher beim Ende von Mao und bei Deng anzukommen, dann die autoritäre Wende zu Xi, um von da aus wieder zu sagen, was die jetzt so alles machen. Ich weiß gar nicht, für wen das geschrieben ist, weil ich sag mal, für die Leute, die sich für so etwas interessieren, die kennen diese Sachen. Wir alle haben jetzt 17 Putin-Dokumentationen bei Arte gesehen, die auch alle sehr sehenswert sind, oder die meisten zumindest von ihnen. Wir bekommen hier noch mal so einen Rundumschlag von dem, um uns quasi zu zeigen, ja, der Putin, das ist wirklich ein gefährlicher Mann. Wer hätte es gedacht? Dabei erfahre ich aber so wenig über diese Frage, was hat denn das jetzt gerade wirtschaftlich zu bedeuten? Und die Wirtschaftsthese eigentlich war die schon erwähnte, die allem zugrunde liegt. Ja, weil die wirtschaftlich Probleme bekommen werden, werden sie dann zu militärischen Schritten übergehen. Und das gehen wir gleich mal in der Argumentation durch, denn da entstehen doch erhebliche Widersprüche, wie ich meine. Dass sie sagt, Geld braucht man zur Finanzierung des Krieges. Und die Wirtschaft kann auch Krieg führen über strategische Korruption, über Sanktionen. All das ist okay. Wenn sie dann die These aufstellt, Geld ist die Waffe aller Waffen, ist das hochinteressant. Aber leider kommt da nicht viel.
Also ihr Satz lautet, Waffen kosten Geld. Und was das Geld zur eigentlichen Waffe macht, es ist die Waffe aller Waffen. Das ist keine inhaltliche Auflösung des Titels, sondern das ist einfach eine alberne Tautologie, bei der man völlig zurecht, wie du am Anfang fragen kann, ich gebe mein Geld für Komfort aus, ist das jetzt Waffenhandel?
Vor allem, wenn man diese Tautologie mitnimmt, muss man ja fragen, woher kommt dann also das Geld? Und da wissen wir ja dank MMT, dass da manche Länder mehr, manche weniger abhängig oder unabhängig sind bei der Emittierung von Geld. Wir wissen, dass die USA sich jetzt ohne Weiteres weiter verschulden kann, um zum Beispiel Waffen zu produzieren. Wo gerät das zum Beispiel in Russland an Grenzen? Also das sind so Sachen, bei denen ich mich frage, was ist damit gesagt? Und dann sagt sie auch zugleich wieder, ach, da fällt mir eine Ausnahme ein. Im Bezug auf Geld ist die Waffe aller Waffen. In Saigon war das ja nicht so. Also wir haben natürlich beim Vietnamkrieg einen ganz mächtigen Akteur, einen Wirtschaftsakteur mit den USA. Wir haben aber zugleich dort ein eigentlich armes Land, das aber aus ideologischen Beweggründen trotzdem dabei ist. Und jetzt könnten wir nämlich genauso auf den Iran blicken und das da auch so sehen.
Das stimmt. Und von daher sind wir hier nicht nur weit weg von einem theoretischen Unterbau, sondern wir sind ganz eng an zwei historischen Beispielen, die eigentlich nicht zueinander passen wollen. Russland und China, die sich sehr unterschiedlich entwickeln. Das eine Land investiert nur und das andere Land verkonsumiert alles und sie bindet es trotzdem am Ende wieder zusammen und sagt und deswegen müssen wir die beide in einem Rutsch beobachten, nämlich so und so. Also das müssen wir langsam entfalten, weil das ist ja wirklich irre, das so zu machen. Sie macht aber am Anfang, bevor sie hier kurz auf Sönke Neizl zu sprechen kommt, ist ein kleiner Hoffnungsschirm am Text, denn sie beschreibt diese Russland-China-Allianz als stille Allianz, was ja bedeutet, es reicht völlig, wenn die locker zusammenarbeiten, weil da entfaltet sich ja, was ich eben beschrieb, und das hat ja auch das Kartellrecht häufig als Herausforderung, dass der eine Tankstellenbesitzer bei dem anderen Tankstellensbesitzer vorbei fährt, sein Preisniveau sieht und sich anpasst. Und dann kommen die Wettbewerbshüter und suchen eine Absprache. Und die gibt es natürlich nicht. So. Und von daher, ja, es gibt eine Entwicklung, dass sich diese beiden Länder ewige Freundschaft erklären, bis Februar 22 noch die grenzenlose Freundschaft, der beste Freund, so Xi über Putin. Und im Grunde explodieren dann in folgenden Jahren auch die Abhängigkeiten. Also wie viel Öl fließt oder Gas fließt nach China, wie viel Material fließt zurück. 80 Prozent der elektronischen Komponenten, den russischen Drohnen kommen aus China, schreibt sie. Nur genau als das eigentlich zu entfalten ist, also wie so eine strukturelle Zusammenhänge sind von Ländern, die, wie sie selber schreibt, ja unvereinbar, also wirklich inkompatibel sind. Ja, auch ideologisch. Genau, kommt sie dann auf Putins schrumpfendes Zeitfenster. Sönke Neitzl hat gesagt, noch drei Jahre und dann kommt der große Angriff.
Ich zitiere das mal. Der neue Weltkrieg könnte jederzeit beginnen. Die nächsten drei Jahre sind die gefährlichsten, behandelt der Militärhistoriker Sönke Neitzl im Sommer 2025. Denn momentan verfügen die Russen über weit mehr Waffen und aktive Soldaten als die europäischen NATO-Staaten. Zugleich kann Russland diese Hochrüstung aber nicht lange durchhalten, weil sie die russische Wirtschaft zu stark belastet. Putin könnte daher versucht sein, seinen militärischen Vorsprung noch möglichst schnell zu nutzen, bevor die europäischen NATO-Mitglieder aufgeholt haben.
Gleichzeitig kommt sie aber später darauf zu sprechen, 2014 als so eine Semi-Annexion des Dombars stattfindet, bricht das dort um 70 Prozent ein in Wirtschaftskraft. Und es ist ein absolutes Minusgeschäft für Russland. An die Krim muss jedes Jahr Milliarden überwiesen werden. Also welchen Vorteil würde Putin nutzen im Sinne von, ich habe noch drei Gewehre, während die nur zwei haben, ich kann also mehr schießen. Aber was ist das Ziel? Das ist ja völlig unklar.
Das kann sie uns hier nicht sagen.
Völlig unklar.
Und Deutschland ist dabei aber das wichtigste Aufmarschgebiet.
Das sollen wir uns also schon klar machen. Das ist natürlich dann die Ulf-Burmeier-Talkshow-Logik. Ja, schon richtig. Die Front wird dann in Polen sein. Das macht uns aber zum Aufmarschgebiet. Bitte seien sie erschrocken und gewarnt. Ich habe es ihnen gesagt, ihre Töchter werden Brücken reparieren oder was auch immer. Also die ganze Argumentation hat kein wirtschaftliches Fundament. Und umso wirrer, dass dieses Buch einfach trotzdem weitergeht.
Ja, ich hatte auch an manchen Stellen gedacht, das hätte eine interessante E-Mail werden können, aber nicht ein ganzes Buch. Zumal ich nicht verstehe, wie man dann mit so einer dürftigen Grundlage sagt, ich baue da 250 Seiten drauf auf. Weil sie eigentlich dann sehr viel von dem reproduziert, was wir kennen und was auch nicht alles falsch ist. Ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass sie jetzt hier Fehler macht. Man kann auch Dinge nach googeln und dann wird man auch das bestätigt sehen. Die Sache ist nur, das geschlossene Weltbild, das sie damit zimmert, das hält nicht stand. Dass sie da einzelne Entwicklungen aufzeigt, völlig richtig. Nur, was sie dann im Ganzen davon ableitet, das funktioniert nicht. Wenn sie sagt, Putin und Xi sind da ökonomisch in einer schwierigen Lage und um davon abzulenken, müssen sie Kriege führen. Wir aber zugleich erfahren, dass diese Kriege für diese Mächte katastrophal werden und in Russland könnte man das eben schon sehr gut beobachten und lange wird das Geld nicht mehr reichen, etc. Dann gibt es ja da offenbar einen Widerspruch, den müsste man ja auflösen. Wie schildert sie nun Putins Dilemma? Frieden wäre daher riskant für Putin. Also sie sagt, der will gar nicht Frieden in der Ukraine, weil das dann erst ein Risiko für Putin gibt. Sobald der Krieg endet, wäre der russische Diktator mit der unangenehmen Frage konfrontiert, wie die Ex-Soldaten eigentlich ihren Lebensunterhalt verdienen sollten. Denn im Frieden würden die russischen Waffenspäden nicht mehr expandieren, sodass die veteranen Jobs in zivilen Betrieben finden müssten, die es aber kaum noch gibt. Zudem wäre ja nicht nur die Ex-Soldaten auf Stellensuche, sondern auch viele Arbeitskräfte aus der Rüstungsindustrie. Der Umbau von einer Kriegs- zur Friedenswirtschaft würde Jahre dauern, falls es überhaupt gelingt. Das ist also jetzt die These, dass Putin einen Kriegskainsianismus macht, wo ich dann sagen würde, Putin könnte ja, wenn das jetzt das Anliegen wäre, auch einen Friedenskainsianismus betreiben und würde in Industrien, die sich lohnen, groß investieren und hätte das machen können. Es gibt ja nicht diese Notwendigkeit, nur Kriegskainsianismus zu machen. Das ist ja gerade das Verrückte auch in Deutschland, dass man sich zwar entschließt, Kriegskainsianismus zu machen, im Sinne von, da investieren wir stark in die Aufrüstung. Bildung, nee, da lassen wir uns mal lieber was streichen, wo man ja auch sagen könnte, da machen wir doch lieber einen Friedenskainsianismus. Geht für mich nicht zusammen, was sie hier ausführt.
Ja, genau. Also wir sind ja hier noch in der Einleitung. Später soll ja eine Entfaltung folgen. Und es ist ein ganz interessantes Paradox, denn man fragt sich ja, wie jetzt vorhin schon bei Mirana gesprochen und so, wie genau funktioniert es auf der Straße? Also wie macht die National gerade das ganz konkret, sich einfach ein Quadratkilometer zu sichern? Also sie schreibt zum einen, das hast du ja eben schon genannt, Putin und Xi haben sich in ökonomische Sackgassen manövriert, die ihre Machtbasis bedrohen. Für beide Diktatoren könnte es daher reizvoll sein, Kriege zu beginnen, um von diesen ökonomischen Problemen abzulenken. Jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage, also wenn im Fernsehen davon die Rede ist, wir führen gerade Krieg, verdrängt das dann wirtschaftliche Nachrichten und damit ist das dann erfolgreich abgelenkt, das Volk? Also das ist sozusagen, wo genau, wie ist der Mechanismus?
Und warum muss der überhaupt seine Bevölkerung ablenken? Also wir haben es ja in Russland mit einer Diktatur zu tun.
Das kommt noch dazu, genau.
Also die kann ja, und auch die Präsidentie kann ja, wie wir wissen, durchregieren. Also es würde ja noch auf einer demokratischen Ebene Sinn ergeben, wenn man sagt, ja, ich muss die nächste Wahl gewinnen, ich lenke die mal kurz ab, marschiere mal irgendwo ein, schnapp mir den Maduro oder was auch immer, damit die sehen, ich bin ein starker Präsident, deswegen werden die mich wieder wählen. Für Putin ist das doch, es ist ja ein Gewaltregime, bei dem sowieso nicht die Frage ist, wie beliebt ist er jetzt gerade.
Ihre Widersprüche sind ja wirklich fundamental. Zum einen zum Vorgängerbuch, denn sie beschreibt ja hier nun, okay, beide Länder könnten mit Krieg ablenken. Putin macht das jetzt schon und sie beschreibt uns ja schon, in welche ökonomische Lage das Russland bringt. Also da ist ja nicht mehr viel mit Ablenkung, das ist nur noch Repression. In China beschreibt sie ja 40 Prozent Investitionsquote. Ich habe euren Diskurs noch im Ohr in Wohlstand für alle, wo ihr auch kurz darüber debattiert habt, wie viel Binnwirtschaft kann denn Xi zulassen und warum macht er es nicht? So und da stellt sich ja wirklich die Frage, wenn 20 Prozent der Jugendlichen arbeitslos sind und sie immer nur hören, hier, wir sind jetzt wieder Schlüsseltechnologie, hier und da und das halbe Land denkt sich so, ja aber ich bin gar nicht so ein toller Mathematiker oder was auch immer. Also kann man den nicht einfach jetzt den Servicebereich aufmachen, dass man sagt, hier wir zahlen jetzt grundsätzlich mal mehr damit, klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber das ist dann die Lösung, wir uns jetzt alle mal ein bisschen die Haare schneiden. Das kann ja China wirklich sehr viel retten.
Ja, bei so einer großen Binnenwirtschaft. Ist zumindest meine Auffassung, mein lieber Freund Ohle würde das dann anders sehen, aber das ist eine alte Debatte, die wir dauernd führen.
Genau und ich finde aber hier für Xi ist ja völlig klar, der muss ja das Land auch so ein bisschen arm halten, weil Arm heißt ja gefügig. Der hat also nicht einfach so eine, der hat genug Probleme mit den Oligarchen, die er hat sozusagen.
Und es gibt ja noch einen anderen Grund, und da gebe ich ja Ohle durchaus recht. China will ja offenbar, auch wenn das Ulrike Herrmann die ganze Zeit hier schreibt, sich nicht entkoppeln, sondern legt ja mit der Seidenstraße und allem, das sind ja gerade keine Entkopplungsprojekte, legt ja gerade alles daran, so zu werden, wie Deutschland mal war, also als Exportmodell, als man möchte ein Wirtschaftsmodell haben, das auf den Export ausgerichtet ist. Und in der Hinsicht kann es natürlich in der Logik Sinn ergeben, zu sagen, ich will, dass meine Bevölkerung keine besonders hohen Löhne bekommt, damit hier doch günstig produziert werden kann, damit wir entsprechend exportieren können. Und deswegen müsste dann auch der Dienstleistungssektor dürfte nicht so gestärkt werden mit höheren Löhnen, denn sonst würde das ja generell eine Lohndynamik geben. Also das ist die Idee hier.
So, das bedeutet aber, sowohl nach innen ist das zentrale Argument soziale Stabilität als auch nach außen. Also gerade nicht Krieg, Chaos und Verderben für den Weg, den sich Russland Putin entschieden hat.
Zumal ich aber auch sagen würde, sowohl jetzt die Begehrlichkeiten Chinas gegenüber Taiwan wie Russland gegenüber Ukraine haben ja ein geopolitisches Interesse, das relativ leicht benannt werden kann.
Darauf will ich ja meine Pointe jetzt Münzen. Falls Xi Taiwan überfällt und nach den Militärübungen zu urteilen, würde ich sagen, das ist wirklich sehr wahrscheinlich und die nächsten zehn Jahre wird es wahrscheinlich auch passieren. Wo kommt denn diese Idee her, das zu machen? Jedenfalls nicht als Ableitung aus den innenpolitischen Problemen, die man hat oder den externen ökonomischen, sondern, und da würde ich halt sagen, das ist die eigentliche Pointe, die man jetzt machen muss 2026. Wenn Donald Trump innerhalb eines Jahres es schafft, Kuba, Venezuela, Kanada, Grönland zu bedrohen und sogar militärisch schon tätig zu werden, warum sollte China das denn nicht machen?
So, aus dieser Logik heraus. Und sie haben diese besonderen Häfen, die sie da bauen könnten. Das wurde ja auch schon mal hier im Podcast verhandelt für, ich glaube, atomar bewaffnete U-Boote. Da gibt es also strategische Vorteile, wenn man Taiwan hat. Es gibt außerdem sowieso diese Idee, dass Taiwan zu China gehört. Das ist ja auch eine ewig lange Debatte. Sie haben also ein geopolitisches Interesse möglicherweise, das so stark dann ist, dass es dazu führt, dass Taiwan angegriffen wird. Aber das ist keine Ablenkungsmanöver. Und Putin, wir wissen, wie er die NATO-Ost-Erweiterung sieht. Wir mögen das alle anders sehen oder Teile von uns anders sehen. Das spielt aber keine Rolle, was ich dazu denke. Putin sieht das so. Das ist die Bedrohung für Russland, weshalb die Ukraine für ihn als Gebiet enorm wichtig ist, um dort seine Stärke zu demonstrieren und um diese EU-Erweiterung beziehungsweise NATO-Ost-Erweiterung zu stoppen. Das ist das geopolitische Interesse da. Und das ist kein Ablenkungsmanöver. Er muss ja eher vom Kriege ablenken, weshalb ja in den russischen Medien, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt immer noch so ist, aber zumindest in den ersten zwei Jahren, nur von einer militärischen Operation gesprochen wurde.
Genau, wie Amerika jetzt über die Iran spricht.
Ja, damit man nicht die Leute irre macht mit einem Krieg. Ich erinnere mich auch bei dieser Ablenkung. Ich denke, wir wissen ja, sie nennt ja hier Zahlen, ich weiß nicht, woher sie die hat, von über einer Million Tote und Verletzte auf russischer Seite.
Habe ich auch versucht zu googeln.
Ja, habe ich nicht gefunden. Nehmen wir mal an, sie stimmen. Dann würde ich sagen, dann gerät man ja als Präsident doch unter mehr Rechtfertigungsdruck, als wenn man jetzt sagt, ja, die Wirtschaft dümpelt gerade ein bisschen dahin. Wir wissen ja selbst in einer solchen Gesellschaft, dass natürlich diese Todeszahlen entsprechend was machen in der Bevölkerung und nicht alle jubeln lassen, weil dann irgendwann jeder einen kennt, der entweder sehr entstellt oder tot nach Hause gekommen ist.
Genau. Und damit, das muss man leider so sagen, steht das ganze Buchkopf. Denn dieses Buch besteht aus drei großen Kapiteln. Eins zu Russland, eins zu China, eins zu Europa. Und diese werden ganz interessant geclustert. Denn bei Russland und China zeigt sie uns, will sie uns zeigen, warum es fast unausweichlich ist, dass diese Länder in den Krieg ziehen werden. Oder eben schon sind sie. Ich möchte uns den Ukrainikrieg über diese Art Retrospektiv erklären und schon mal vorwarnen, dass Taiwan passiert. Und im dritten Kapitel wird dann über die EU gesprochen und was die EU machen müsste, um das irgendwie zu verhindern oder damit umzugehen, wie auch immer. So, und da würde ich sagen, nee, meine Lesart ist einfach grundsätzlich anders und wird durch ihr Schreiben auch nicht, also nicht mal irritiert, dass wir derzeit eine Nachrichtenlage haben, in der Xi sieht, also ich habe die letzten 50 Jahre kein Krieg angefangen, mein Land hat kein Krieg angefangen. Klar, wir haben ein Bedrohungsszenario aufgebaut, aber mehr so als noch mediales Schauspiel, bis wir dann bei Taiwan so nahe gerückt sehen, dass sie uns mit bloßem Auge sehen, wie wir da eine Landungsoperation planen und so. Nur die Idee, so was tatsächlich zu machen, also von Drohung in Gewalt überzugehen, das liegt halt wirklich daran auch, dass die Europäische Union daneben steht und ein bisschen lächelt, wenn es um Venezuela geht, ein bisschen Sorge äußert, wenn es um Kanada geht, wenn es um Grönland geht. Wow, da wird ja die EU selber ein bisschen angegriffen. Ja, dann sagen wir immer noch nichts. Das können wir uns immer noch mit Kommentaren schön schreiben. Ja klar, denkt Xi dann, Momentchen mal, also warum hole ich mir jetzt nicht Taiwan? Was soll denn hier passieren? So. Ja, also es ist genau nicht die Logik des Buches, dass Europa die Hoffnung ist, sondern Europa stürzt uns mit in dieses kognitive Lernchaos von Xi, dass er irgendwann zu dem Schluss kommt. Klar, greife ich jetzt Taiwan an. Warum nicht? Also wer soll denn hier zahlen? Soll jetzt die USS Ford hier vorfahren oder was? Ist ja völlig bescheuert.
Ja, also man muss ja jetzt auch kein extremer Anti-Imperialist sein, um doch hier etwas sehr Eigenartiges zu merken. Während wir Akteure in China haben und in Russland, sehen wir hier den Westen als ja geradezu unschuldig reagierend auf das, was da an Unheil immer von dort und da kommt. Das finde ich auch ganz eigenartig, als hätte also der Westen, als hätte auch die EU überhaupt gar kein eigenes Projekt, gar kein eigenes Interesse, das sie irgendwo durchsetzt, sondern uns widerfährt jetzt einfach so Geschichte grundsätzlich, wie uns das schon eine ganze Weile so widerfährt einfach. Also sie blendet da ganz aus, was da eigentlich los ist und finde auch dann ihre Formulierungen ja doch sehr kritikwürdig, wenn sie zum Beispiel von China spricht. Also sie redet da davon, dass unglaublich viele Investitionen stattfinden seitens der chinesischen Regierung. Also 40,4 Prozent des chinesischen Volkseinkommens werden in Investitionen gelenkt. Das stimmt auch und ja, das ist nicht ganz beispiellos, wie sie beschreibt für die Welt. Aber ja, das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was einem ins Auge fällt. Aber die Produktivitätszuwächse sind bei Null. Offenbar, schreibt sie jetzt, wirft China sein Geld zum Fenster hinaus und investiert vor allem in Projekte, die niemand braucht. Die Liste ist lang. Dazu gehören leere Wohnblocks, aufgeplähte Staatskonzerne sowie überschüssige Produkte, die zu subventionierten Dumpingpreisen auf den Weltmarkt geschwemmt werden. Sie spricht an anderen Stellen auch noch von von Schrott. Aber kann man das wirklich so einfach stehen lassen? Also wir sehen ja, dass jemand wie Adam Tooze, der sich da meinen Augen besser auskennt, auch sagt, natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, die produzieren Überkapazitäten. Aber müssen wir wirklich angesichts von Solarpaneelen, die wir überall brauchen, von Überkapazitäten reden? Wäre nicht also erst das Problem, dass wir aus dem Westen nicht bereit sind, diese chinesischen Produkte abzukaufen, um hier endlich erneuerbare Energien flächendeckend zu haben. Also Sättigung ist ja global nicht erreicht, was das anbelangt. Deswegen kann man da eigentlich nicht von Überkapazitäten reden. Haben wir den Eindruck bei diesen Hightech-Zügen in China, bei dem, was auch tatsächlich gebaut wurde, man muss sich das ja klammern, in den letzten 30 Jahren, über 80% aller Gebäude wurden da gebaut. Also, dass es da Fehlallokationen im hohen Maße gibt und dass man glaubt, da auch den Immobiliensektor immer weiter aufplänen zu können, sei ja zugestanden. Aber das jetzt so darzustellen, als hätten die so eine völlig missratene Wirtschaftspolitik nur gemacht, das würde ich doch ein bisschen in Zweifel ziehen.
Also, ich würde hier einfach sagen, es gibt ja diesen, wir haben schon ein paar mal angesprochen, sehr interessantes Podcast mit Robert Reich, ist es glaube ich, der aus China zurückkam und mit Israel klein im Gespräch war und meinte, wir verstehen China komplett falsch. Das Problem ist, zu Corona hat der ganze Westen China verlassen und kehrte danach nicht zurück. Was wir von China sehen sind also Kennziffern von außen. In den Kennziffern, diesen Running Gag gibt es ja seit Jahrzehnten, hat sich die Etablierung des Computers niemals gezeigt. Genauso wie das Internet und jetzt die KI. Also die Produktivitätsermessungen schlagen sich da einfach nicht nieder. Von daher ist der Blick von außen mit dieser Urteilskraft, wie sie das macht, sowieso schief und krumm. Aber lassen wir uns doch beim Russland-Kapitel anfangen, da sie das auch voranstellt und es uns auch sehr liegt.
Also wir waren jetzt nur bei der Einleitung. Das waren jetzt alles Passagen aus der Einleitung, die wir gelesen haben. Wir kommen jetzt zum ersten Kapitel. Russland war immer schwach, zeigt sie uns da.
Rückständig, ja.
Putin hat keine konkurrenzfähige Industrie. Russland wollte immer zum Westen aufschließen, es gelang nicht. Dann beschreibt sie erst einmal die bürokratische Herrschaft in der Sowjetunion. Davor noch geht sie ja bis zu den Zaren zurück und geht da ja so schlaglichtartig durch die Geschichte, um zu sagen, die Zarenherrschaft wurde dann irgendwann abgesäbelt, ersetzt durch eine Diktatur der Bürokratie.
Ja, also wenn sie ihren historischen Habitus, den sie hier an den Tag legen, ernst nehmen könnte, dann würde es schon interessante Sachen drinstecken. Wir fragen uns ja alle gerade so ein bisschen, was hat es mit diesem slawischen Brutalismus auf sich, der ja zum Teil schon in Ostdeutschland beginnt. Also manchmal sind ja Touristen aus Rheinland-Pfalz erschrocken darüber, wie schroff sie einfach in Sachsen behandelt werden.
Das willst du jetzt so ethnisch darstellen, als slawischer Brutalismus?
Ja, es gibt...
Da hätte ich ja doch meine Bedenken.
Ja, ich weiß schon, sehr viele Hörer werden jetzt auch wieder was kommentieren. Aber es gibt Theorien zum Thema, die Elbe trennt dann... Also das Slawische beginnt doch recht früh und erscheint zu eigen anzugeben.
Nein, nein, also das sind Projektionen, die sich ja doch relativ... Also das kann man ja wirklich jetzt gut nachvollziehen, selbst in diesem Buch, die sich natürlich aus Umständen ergeben, die von großer Armut, von Gewaltherrschaft in verschiedenen Ausprägungen geprägt sind. Das heißt, das ist ja nicht irgendetwas, was den Menschen dort zu eigen ist, sondern wir sehen einfach dort ein bitterkaltes System, was das Soziale anbelangt. Und das nicht erst seit Putin, sondern hat eine sehr lange historische Tradition. Und dass daraus natürlich dann auch eine Gewalt erwächst, das ist ja keine neue Sache. Ich will nur davor warnen, weil wir ja gerade nicht diesen Diskurs haben wollen, den wir jetzt zum Beispiel haben in Bezug auf Flüchtlinge, die kommen. Da wird dann auch, ich habe es ja in rechten Podcasts erlebt, dann gesagt, ja, aber die sind vielleicht so.
Ja, deswegen folgender Bogenschlag. Sie beschreibt das und deswegen sage ich, das ist historisch ein bisschen unverständlich, weil sie bricht es eben materiell nieder und sagt, es gab schon Autoren im 19. Jahrhundert, die zahl Nikolaus als eigentlichen Genghis Khan mit einem Telegrafen. Darstellten dann gab es Kommentatoren, die später Stalin als Genghis Khan mit einem Telefon darstellten. Und was wir feststellen ist, dass es ja hier immer eine Verknüpfung gibt aus. Na ja, ich gehe, ich regiere schon relativ hart, aber ich liebe die Künste. Wir haben die besten Schachspieler, das beste Ballett, was auch immer, die beste Musik. So und genau das sehen wir jetzt auch wieder bei Donald Trump. Der ist ja genau von sowas fasziniert. Von daher ist diese historisch, müsste man sie mal formulieren als, da ist so ein slawisches Gebiet, dass das gar nicht so ein slawisches Gebiet im geografischen Sinne ist, sondern dass es hier so Macht, Machtstrukturen gibt, die darauf hinauslaufen, denen auch der Westen jetzt wieder zum Opfer fällt. Denn als ich das so las, dachte ich, habe ich mich dran erinnert, wie Esra Klein auch mal so ein kleines Snippet gemacht hat, so ein 15 Minuten Meinungsstück zum Thema, ist Donald Trump nicht eigentlich ein Eier toller? So. Und das fand ich irgendwie schlüssig. Ja, also von daher, es scheint hier so Sachen zu geben, die einfach prägen. Und Sie müssen es natürlich komplett auf Putin.
Ja, es ist eine Prägung. Ja, sie erzählt eigentlich dieses Kapitel so, dass da am Ende Putin bei rauskommen muss. Und das meine ich ja, dass sie so eine Stringenz einbaut in ihre Argumentation, dass man erst einmal, wenn man es so liest, denkt, ah ja, genau, klar. Und dann folgt das eine auf das andere. Man kann diese Geschichten selbstverständlich auch anders erzählen.
Ja, und am Ende rätseln wir ja genau über solche Stränge immer, warum ist Putin so enttäuscht vom Westen, was auch immer. Und wir lesen dann, dass er in seinem Millenniumsmanifest am 31.12.1999, also er ist schon Präsident, aber ist noch das alte Jahrhundert, unter anderem den Satz unterbringt, wenn wir es 15 Jahre lang schaffen, ein jährliches Wirtschaftswachstum von 10% zu erzielen, holen wir Großbritannien oder Frankreich ein. Das bedeutet für mich als vulgär Psychologe, Putin ist ein wahnsinnig enttäuschter Typ. Er hat Russland ein Angebot gemacht und die Bevölkerung hat nicht mitgezogen. Also soll sie leiden. Also hier steckt auch so ein bisschen Sadismus sich selbst gegenüber drin, ausgespielt im Volk. Sowas hätte ich zum Beispiel, wenn man schon so rein spekuliert wie sie und so hier und da mal Sachen zusammensammeln, ja, dann würde ich mir dann auch einfach, dass man im Text schon markiert. Ich schlage jetzt hier wirklich strenger, aber hier mal ein Denkangebot. Aber finde ja leider auch nicht statt. Stattdessen werden uns einfach die Historien seit den Zarenreich, aber mit einer interessanten Paradoxie, wie ich noch sagen würde, und zwar, wie hat das Zarenreich ein Ausbeutersystem, wie mit den eigenen Bauern, eigentlich etabliert? Und sie macht so eine Gegenüberstellung. Russland und England. In England ist einfach der Raum geografisch knapp. Das heißt, Leuten, denen ich so eine kleine Furche gebe, damit sie da Getreide anbauen, die können gar nicht flüchten. Ich muss sie also auch nicht an dieses Stück Land binden. Das ist natürlich in Russland ganz anders. Ich kann in Russland diesen Bauern keine kognitive Freiheit zugestehen, weil die dann einfach immer flüchten. Ich muss sie irgendwie an die Scholle binden und damit auch an mich. Also entsteht aus dieser natürlichen Freiheit eine politische Zwanghaftigkeit, die einfach im Rest Europa so nicht historisch sich niederschlug. Das finde ich schon eine interessante Beobachtung. Da steckt bestimmt einiges drin.
Das ist so die umgekehrte Frontier-These. In den USA ist gerade die Weite des Landes die Möglichkeit, also überall hinzugehen und neue Freiheit suchen.
Man hat sie immer gelassen. Und in Russland hat man sie eben nicht gelassen, sondern da gab es immer durch hier reichisiert von oben nach unten diese strenge Zentralität.
Sie weist dann noch mal darauf hin, wie der Zweite Weltkrieg Russland natürlich prägt. Selbst der Zweite Weltkrieg konnte den Fortschritt nicht mehr aufhalten. Also der Aufstieg zur Supermacht, der gelang dann, obwohl die Verluste an Menschenleben entsetzlich waren. 7 Millionen sowjetische Soldaten wurden von der deutschen Wehrmacht getötet. Von den 18-Jährigen, die 1941 zur Roten Armee eingezogen worden waren, lebten 1945 nur noch 3 Prozent. Zudem kamen 17 bis 20 Millionen Zivilisten um. Und nach dem Krieg verhungerten noch einmal 2 Millionen. Das sind die Zahlen, die wir hier haben. Von daher ist Russland dort in einer miserablen Situation arm, weshalb wir dann auch eben eine andere Geschichte erzählen konnten davon, dass es doch erstaunlich ist, wie sehr sich die Sowjetunion dann doch entwickeln konnte in den 50er-, 60er-Jahren. Also, dass das überhaupt nach all dem, was geschehen ist, und auch aus dieser bitteren Armut, aus der sie kommen, also vom Zarenreich her, und trotz der bürokratischen Herrschaft in der Sowjetunion, was ja dann so eine Diktatur der Bürokratie tatsächlich war, auch im Sinne von eines großen Selbstbedienungsladens, ist es ja eigentlich dann ganz erstaunlich, dass doch auch Wirtschaftsprogramme, zum Beispiel auch ein großes Bauprogramm, Wohnungen für alle, sehr weit getragen hat in den 50er und 60er Jahren.
Aber ich will noch mal einen kleinen Schnittsprung zurück machen vor den Zweiten Weltkrieg. Denn eine Sache, die ich so nicht wusste, aber ich bin jetzt auch kein Marx und Engels Leser, und du aber, das ist ganz interessant. Also es entsteht im Westen schon diese Art von Kapitalismus und man sieht, man will hier irgendwie nacheifern, es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Wettbewerb. Und dann ist die Frage, wie baut man diesen Kommunismus auf? Und es gibt konkurrierende Ideen. Das eine ist, man sagt, die Dorfgemeinschaft, wie wir sie vorfinden, also Bauern, sind der Nukleus, denn dort ist ja schon Kommunismus, wir haben das ja bei Rutger Bredigmann auch so als Elementar-Kommunismus ausgeprägt. Und dann kommt aber Engels, also Marx ist ein Anhänger von dieser Idee, dass die bäuerliche Gemeinde der Ausgangspunkt ist, dann kommt aber Engels und sagt, nee, wir brauchen hier so Entwicklungsstadien, es sind auf gar keinen Fall die Bauern, es sind die Fabrikarbeiter. Und aufgrund dieser Idee, sagt sie, sind dann später auch diese Millionen Toten unter der Bauernschaft zu verzeichnen, weil Stalin sich auch einfach dachte, wozu brauche ich die Bauern? Ich brauche die Fabrikarbeiter.
Also es ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Es gibt bei Marx tatsächlich Überlegungen, es gibt ja auch Texte zu Russland und zu Polen, wo er sich dann fragt, ob man quasi ohne erst mal diese kapitalistische Entwicklung durchzumachen, gleich zum Sozialismus kommen kann oder ob man dann eher erst den Kapitalismus braucht, um dann zum Sozialismus zu kommen. Während Branko Milanović ja die schöne These präsentierte in einem seiner vorherigen Bücher, dass der Kapitalismus den Sozialismus brauchte in diesen Ländern, nämlich in den armen Ländern, um zum Kapitalismus zu bekommen. Also der Sozialismus war die Brücke zum Kapitalismus und nicht umgekehrt. Und das ist eine interessante Debatte. Es gibt ja auch das Buch von Kohei Saito, der auch da eigentlich aufzeigen will, nein, man braucht eigentlich nicht eine weitere kapitalistische Beschleunigung, um zum Sozialismus zu kommen. Ich bin eher auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich das jetzt mal so grob beantworten würde, würde ich sagen, das ist schon die Entwicklungsstufe Kapitalismus, die dann hinführt zum Sozialismus. Aber das ist nochmal eine andere Debatte jetzt hier.
Du bist aber gar kein richtiger Marxist, du bist schließlich ja auch Engelslinie.
Nein, nein, ich würde sagen, das ist ein bisschen gesucht der Marxist. Also es gibt da unterschiedliche Ausdehnungen. Ich bin auch gar nicht so tief drin, um das jetzt in allen Details zu klären. Aber es gibt durchaus Leute, die sagen, nein, nein, das hat zwar Marx da auch mal beschäftigt, aber das ist eigentlich nur peripher, während anderes wichtiger ist. Jedenfalls kann man festhalten, dass natürlich diese Missachtung, was die Bauern einfach liefern, nämlich Nahrung, natürlich dazu geführt hat, dass man ja nicht nur mit den Bauern schlecht bzw. mörderisch umgegangen ist, sondern dass man auch diese entsprechenden Hungersnöte nicht nur erlitten hat, sondern zum Teil ja wirklich produziert hat oder nichts dagegen getan hat.
Im Kapitalismus werden die Bauern ausgebeutet, indem ihnen zu wenig Preise gezahlt werden. In diesem russischen sowjetischen Kommunismus 1921 bis 1923 ziehen einfach bewaffnete Brigaden durchs Land, greifen denen, wie sie dann auch schreibt, Mehrwert ab mit Schlagnahmen 80 Prozent des Getreides, womit eben sowohl die Selbstversorgeranteile als auch die neue Ernte, die neue Saat gemeint ist und fünf bis sieben Millionen Menschen sterben. Also es ist alles sehr drastisch. Aber trotzdem die Frage, also historisch ist das super interessant, also Wikipedia-Artikel mega, aber unter Geld als Waffe, warum Europa jetzt was machen muss, ist es so ein bisschen Textstücke, die sich in einem Zettelkasten befanden wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich habe wirklich den Eindruck, dass sie auch mal ein bisschen was zu Ostern schreiben wollte und ein bisschen was dazu.
Darf sie auch, aber dann muss sie es mutig unter diesem Label, Geld als Waffe, meine Sicht auf Russland, wie auch immer und so, dass man so ein historisches Ding dann draus macht.
Ja, weil sie auch springt, wenn jetzt manche sagen, aber ihr springt ja hin und her. Ja, sie springt, also sie geht zwar chronologisch vor, aber sie pickt sich dann Dinge heraus. Also sie erzählt ein bisschen was von den Kolschosen, wie unproduktiv die waren. Sie erzählt dann von der Ölkrise in den 70er-Jahren, wie das dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Petrodollars sprudelten bei den Ölfeldern in Sibirien. Plötzlich sind ja die Preise gestiegen, aber Korruption waren dann ein Hautproblem. Dann geht sie über zu 1986. Dann kam der Bankrott. Sie schreibt, den Fall der Sowjetunion hatte niemand vorausgesehen oder gar geplant. Aber Saudi-Arabien traf eine einsame Entscheidung, die das Ende des Sozialismus faktisch besiegelte. Die Saudis ließen nämlich den Ölpreis auf 12 Dollar pro Barel fallen. Rechnete man die Inflation heraus, war das schwarze Gold plötzlich wieder so billig wie vor der Ölkrise von 1973. Der Sowjetunion fehlte nun das Geld, um ihre marode Wirtschaft und ihr Imperium zu subventionieren. Dann geht es um Gorbatschow, der abrüsten will, um Geld zu sparen, der aber auch da sich ein bisschen verrechnet, zum Teil zumindest. Es geht dann um den Ausverkauf Russlands. Also die Eliten haben eigentlich rebelliert und gar nicht so das Volk. Dann ist sie bei Jelsen angekommen. Da ist man dann an dem Punkt, wo diese große Privatisierungswelle stattfindet. Auch das schildert sie dann kurz, sodass die sich für ein paar Millionen Euro Riesenkonzerne aneignen können.
Also Lada wurde damals für 45 Millionen an so einen Typen verkauft. Das hätte man auch für zwei Milliarden an Fiat verhökern können. Man wollte es im Land halten. Damit ist es den Oligarchen zum Opfer gefallen. Und 1996 sind es die 29 wertvollsten Rohstoffunternehmen, die billig versteigert wurden, in die Hände von sieben Männern fielen. Und Russland hat das alles zwölf Milliarden gebracht.
Ja, und diese sieben Männer kontrollierten dann 50 Prozent des Volkseinkommens.
Genau. Ja, so klar, es war ein Schrotthaufen, wie sie sagt. Es war ein Schrotthaufen, der größte Schrotthaufen der Geschichte privatisiert. 15.000 Fabriken, dieser krasse Einbruch der Wirtschaftsleistung um 40 Prozent, haben wir ja zuletzt auch einmal als Historie von Patrick aufgeschlüsselt bekommen. Und ja, damit fiel dieses Land an die Oligarchen. Und da kann man zumindest sagen, okay, dieses Buch ist jetzt heute angekommen. Also zumindest aus dieser Ableitung gibt es einen direkten Bogenschlag zur Kriegsführung von Putin. Hier muss man aber deutlich sagen, dieses Aufkaufen des größten Schrotthaufens der Welt durch russische Oligarchen ist auch für die russische Geschichte ein echter Bruch. Also hier kann man nochmal irgendwie kommen mit, naja Putin als der Genghis Khan das irgendwie und da muss sich halt ein Hof halten und es waren dann die Oligarchen, wie auch immer. Aber so wie sie es bei China sehr, also bei China ist sie sehr wichtig. Die mussten gar nichts reformieren oder umbauen, sondern die konnten einfach neu bauen, weil es gab ja nichts. So würde ich sagen, diese Zäsur der Wände 1989, so wie sie hier im Buch steht, ist so groß, also hier wurden einfach alle historischen Zöpfe abgeschnitten und 15 Männer regierten das Land.
Ja, ich finde das auch ein bisschen eigenartig, wenn wir jetzt eine Wirtschaftsgeschichte erzählen wollten von Deutschland. Also heute wollten das vermessen, wo stehen wir jetzt gerade mit Austritetspolitik und Aufrüstung. Und ich würde sagen, wir müssen erstmal zum alten Fritz zurückgehen.
Ja, also Sozialversicherung und Bismarck würde ich gelten lassen.
Da würde man das noch noch sagen bei der Sozialversicherung. Aber dass ich jetzt den Charakter von Bismarck beschreibe, um was über Helmut Kohl zu sagen, fände ich jetzt schon ein bisschen komisch.
Wobei wir sagen können, alle DAX-Konzerne sind 100 Jahre und älter. Aber ja, hier fand eben keine Zäsur statt.
Ja.
Wie in Russland.
Da findet eine statt.
Ja. Weshalb das halt in Russland so nicht funktioniert.
Zweites Kapitel, also Putin. Die Oligarchen dachten, der ist folgsam wie ein Hündchen. Den nehmen wir uns jetzt. Der wird uns dann beschützen. Aber es kommt dann anders. Dieses Putin-Kapitel arbeitet dann erst mal damit, dass wir so ein paar biografische Einsprengsel bekommen. Putin, wie er aufgewachsen ist, der Vater, eigentlich ein einfacher Mann, aber dann offenbar doch ein bisschen mehr Geld als man als einfacher Mann haben kann. Offenbar hat er also auch schon für den KGB gespitzelt. Putin ist jemand, der von klein auf es mag, andere zu demütigen, um der Mächtige zu sein. Also diese Charakterisierung, die wir alle kennen und die wahrscheinlich auch so stimmen, fragt sich hier auch, warum in dem Buch Geld als Waffe jetzt so ein kleines Putin-Porträt noch mal gezeichnet werden muss. Also wir haben verstanden, dass der bedrohlich ist. Wir wollen ihn nicht als Freund, nein.
Also ich finde, es gibt dafür eine Erklärung. Und der fällt man schnell zum Opfer, wenn man den Fernseher nicht richtig bedienen kann. Dass man nämlich denkt, was im Fernsehen gezeigt wird, ist das Wichtige. Denn so wie dieses Buch hier konzipiert, eine ganz große Fragestellung und dann wird erst mal erklärt, was es mit den Protagonisten auf sich hat. Und dann noch mit Rodochowski als der maßgebliche, also der mächtigste Mann gegen den reichsten Mann. Das ist ja auch die Donald Trump, Elon Musk Geschichte, die uns ja alles aufschlüsseln soll. Das passiert dir, wenn du jahrzehntelang Tagesthemen heute schon alle guckst.
Das ist möglich, ja.
Da wird ja alles runtergebrochen auf... Aber was hat denn jetzt der mächtigste Mann Deutschlands dazu gesagt? Oh, es ist gerade eine Frau, also die mächtigste Frau. Voll variantenreich, die Geschichte. Plötzlich ist es eine Frau, dann ist wieder ein Mann so, ja? So, das ist ja der Variantenreichtum, der Erklärung für alles. Und unter diesem Eindruck finde ich das voll schlüssig, dass man hier zwar kurz andeutet, das ganze Land fiel 15 Oligarchen zum Opfer, aber ich nenne ihnen jetzt keine Namen und das ist auch alles nicht so wichtig, denn Putin. Putin, Putin, Putin, Putin, Putin.
Putin in Dresden, was er da gemacht hat, hat er überhaupt da was gemacht?
Hat er das im Nachhinein verkehrt? Was Putin als junger Mann, und wir können 30, 40 Jahre später immer noch nicht genau sagen, was er da gemacht hat, aber was er da gedacht hat, ist wichtiger als alles, was ansonsten in der russischen Geschichte passiert, weil er heut regiert.
Um dann zu der Schlussfolgerung zu kommen, nachdem wir also diesen kleinen Putin und den jungen Putin und all das schon gehört haben, wie gewaltvoll er ist und wie autoritär er ist, in Putins Welt zählt nur Stärke. Die kleineren Länder hatten sich der Großmacht Russland unterzuordnen. Würde ich sagen, die Geschichte kann man auch anhand von US-Präsidenten erzählen. Die sehen das auch so. Nur gibt es dann eben nicht so eine Story mit, wurde schon zu Hause geschlagen und hat dann Schüler verprügelt.
Umso schöner, dass wir doch jetzt so einen infiniten Regress, so einen richtigen in sich geschlossenen Loop haben, in dem wir einfach Trump als sowieso schon, wir müssen das Land nicht weiter beachten, weil Trump und dann erklären wir Trump ausschließlich mit Putin. Ja.
Punkt.
Das passiert ja. Genau. Das ist ja die Erklärung. Und das ist auch hier, in dem Buch schlägt sich halt nieder.
Ja, dann wird uns erzählt, wie er offenbar sich bereichert hat beim Glücksspiel, wie er das eigentlich einhegen wollte, dann aber wohl doch auch Geldflüsse zu ihm gekommen sind. Denn die Frage stellt sich ja, warum ist Putin so immens reich? Wie wir uns auch die Frage stellen, warum hat Trump so viel Geld? Ist das nur mit Wohnungen in New York passiert? Und wie ist es dann da passiert? Das heißt, da sind wir in dieser üblichen Erzählung, können das dann deckungsgleich uns erzählen. Dann kommt sie zum Chechenienkrieg. Sie zeigt auch da, das sei eigentlich auch schon so ein Ansatz gewesen, der Chechenienkrieg, um von inneren Sachen abzulenken, um eine eigene Stärke herzustellen.
Diese inneren Sachen nennen sie ja kurz, und die sind ja auch interessant, nur die müssen halt entfaltet werden. Also in 15 Amtsjahren finden 200.000 Anklagen gegen Firmeigner statt. Nur 46.000 davon werden vor Gericht verhandelt. 83 Prozent verlieren ihren Betrieb. Das ist doch super interessant. Warum geht man da nicht rein und löst uns genau diese... Ja, ja, da robbte sich halt so nach und nach in der Nationalgarde vor und hat einfach alles sich gekrallt. Die Leute haben ihr Unternehmen verloren. An wen denn? Und zwar nicht jetzt an den Staat oder Putin Skeptokratie, sondern wie genau funktioniert das? In Russland sogar tausende Kilometer von Moskau entfernt hat es trotzdem funktioniert.
Es gibt ja den Ansatz, aber sie bleibt so sehr an Putin hängen. Sie schreibt in Russland, arbeiten nur etwa 20 Prozent der Beschäftigten in kleinen und mittleren Firmen. Während es im europäischen Durchschnitt rund 40 Prozent sind. Stattdessen expandiert der Staatsapparat. Allein in den ersten acht Jahren von Putins Herrschaft wurden drei Millionen neue Stellen in der Verwaltung, beim Militär und in den Staatsbetrieben geschaffen, sodass 40 Prozent aller Arbeitskräfte beim Staat beschäftigt werden. Damit übertrifft das System Putin sogar die Planungsbürokratie der alten Sowjetunion, obwohl Russland heute deutlich kleiner ist und nur noch die Hälfte der Einwohner der UdSSR hat. Was deine These stärkt, dass man sich eigentlich jetzt diese Struktur ansehen müsste, die überhaupt dafür sorgt, dass so ein Putin von einer Wahl zur nächsten schreiten kann, und gar nicht mehr relevant ist, findet da ein richtiger Wahlkampf statt, ist das eine freie Wahl? Nein, natürlich nicht. Braucht es aber auch nicht mehr zu sein. Und wenn eine solche Struktur etabliert ist, dass man dann von dort ausgehend argumentativ sagt, genau und damit die Bevölkerung ruhig gestellt ist, braucht der Putin schon mal draußen in Krieg, damit die nicht aufmucken. Da würde ich sagen, ja hier ist ja die Struktur geschaffen. Deutlicher kann man es ja nicht sagen. Das ist einfach alles voll mit Leuten, die dort arbeiten und diese Sache tun. Das heißt, das ist deren Unternehmung.
Genau, also da ist einfach hier ist mein Interesse sozusagen wirklich geweckt, weil hier wird ja das große russische Schicksal mit den kleinsten möglichen Erklärungen. Jemand braucht einfach am Monatsende eine Gehaltszahlung und die kommt halt vom Staat. Können wir sie wunderbar aufschlüsseln, macht sie aber nicht. Sie nennt aber ein paar Zahlen, die zumindest das Interesse vielleicht jetzt auch bei dem einen oder anderen Hörer wecken können. Also mich würde da Erklärungen zu interessieren. Sie nennt zumindest mal die Namen der Oligarchen, die einfach sterben. Und ich möchte noch mal wirklich untermauern, dass dieses historische Phänomen, was ich jetzt beschreibe oder was ich einfach nur nenne, so wie sie es nennt, zu mehr Stabilität führt. Also dass Putin seit jetzt 30 Jahren oder so da regiert, so 27 Jahren. Das ist auch wirklich erklärungsbedürftig. Also Leonid Schulmann wird tot aufgefunden, ein Gazprom-Manager. Ein Ex-Vize-Präsident Avayev, tot aufgefunden, samt Frau und Tochter tot. Ein Ex-Top-Manager von Novatec Protosenja, tot aufgefunden, samt Frau und Tochter. Ein Lukoi-Top-Manager, Subotin Herzinfarkt, bei einem Schamanen, Kopfschuss im Swimmingpool, bei Yuri Voronov, Ravil Maganov, Lukoi-Chef, September 22, Fenstersturz, noch ein Fenstersturz, durch Pavel Antov, Andrej Badalov, der Vize-Chef von Transneft, Juli 2025, Sturz aus dem 17. Stock in Moskau.
Und das geht noch weiter, also ja.
Wie sowas zu einer sozialen Stabilität führen kann. Die Putin, die Macht sichert. Ohne dass da Leute in Todesangst sagen, wir brauchen ein anderes System, ist erklärungsbedürftig. Und die Erklärung steckt nicht darin, dass man das einfach nennt, dass das das Phänomen ist. Sondern hier müssen, finde ich, Bücher geschrieben werden. Denn vielleicht taucht mal ein amerikanischer Präsident auf, der ein bisschen cleverer ist als Donald Trump, so einer wie JD. Vance. Und man denkt sich so, ups, ist ja längst da. Ist ja längst erklärungsbedürftig. Wer fliegt denn als nächstes in Amerika so aus dem Fenster? Oder hat irgendwelche Herzinfarkte und so? Also hier gibt es wirklich große Erklärungsbedarfe und sie ist auch nah dran. Aber dann bleibt sie in dieser Tagesschau, nicht Tagesschau, sondern Tagesthemen, heute Journal Logik und erklärt uns weiter, was es mit dem Protagonisten Putin nach 2008 auf sich hat, als die russische Wirtschaft dümpelt, man also nicht zu seinem Aufschluss zu England und Frankreich kommt und Putin es trotzdem weiter andermacht.
Ja, und auch da könnte man ja mal darüber reden, wer hat auch diesen Aufstieg verunmöglicht. Also das ist ja auch so interessant, dass wir hier gar nie irgendeinen westlichen Akteur wohl sehen. Also das ist ja auch einfach so, Jelzin ist da Spielball der Oligarchen. Na ja, dass Jelzin nun von den USA installiert wurde, damit das auch genauso verläuft und dass dieser große Ausverkauf dort stattgefunden hat. Da gibt es ja auch nun wirklich eine westliche Beteiligung an dem. Also wir haben ja jetzt nun zwei sehr gute Bücher, einmal von Patrick Kaczmarczyk und von Branko Milanović gelesen, die uns das ja sehr zeigen, welche Entwicklung das in Russland genommen hat und in Entwicklungsländern genommen hat und welche Verantwortung da auch die westlichen Länder haben und in welchem Verhältnis wir da das betrachten sollten. Zudem ist diese Argumentation dann eigenartig, wenn sie erst beschreibt, bevor dann der Krieg 22 in der Ukraine beginnt, gibt es Meinungsumfragen, wie sie zitieren kann, hat Putin Zustimmungswerte von 59 Prozent, was sie sagt, wäre ja in Demokratien sehr gut, aber für Putin dann gar nicht so gut. Doch im März 2022 waren plötzlich 83 Prozent der Russen mit Putin zufrieden. Die Spezialoperation, also in Anführungszeichen, in der Ukraine hat begonnen. Wieder hatte Putin zu seinem bewährten Trick gegriffen, einen Krieg anzuzetteln, um das eigene Volk zu begeistern. Also das ist doch hanebüchend, dass er auf die Meinungsumfrage guckt und dann sagt er, 20 Prozent müsste sich steigern. Jetzt mache ich den Krieg in der Ukraine. Wir haben doch auch die Ausführungen von Militärexperten und so weiter, warum die Ukraine für Putin so entscheidend ist. Also das ist doch, da können wir doch nicht sagen, Meinungsumfragen. Also wir sind dann doch in einer Diktatur, die sich doch erstmal darum gar nicht scheren muss. Und wir sehen ja offenbar, kann man ja wahnsinnig viel treiben und es sehr bunt treiben, ohne dass irgendein Aufstand, irgendeine Rebellion von der Bevölkerung aus zu erwarten ist.
Also da würde ich auch sagen, ihre Argumentation ist halt einfach auf den Sand gebaut, weil sie hat uns jetzt Putin bis dahin ausreichend verteufelt und kommt dann aber mit Stimmungsumfragen, die sie ganz ernst nimmt. Und das passt da nicht, vor allem weil ihr eigenes Anschlusskapitel, ja, Krieg lohnt sich nie, lautet, wie Putin Russland ruiniert hat. Und ich finde, da kommen dann wieder Erklärungen, die es einem verdeutlichen, wenn nämlich geschätzte 20 Prozent der Militärausgaben im Ukraine-Krieg untreut werden und Russland aber vier bis fünf Prozent des BIPs dafür ausgibt, dann fließt ja ein Prozent des BIPs einfach direkt in Korruption. Also dann haben wir es ja wirklich genau mit diesem Nationalgarde-Argument zu tun, wo Putin gar nicht so die großen Anstrengungen machen muss, weil die Leute einfach selber daran interessiert sind, dass das immer weitergeht.
Ich habe mal nachgeschaut, also auf dem Platz bei so einem Korruptionsranking 157, Platz 157 ist Russland da, Ukraine bei 104, ist jetzt auch nicht prächtig. Interessant finde ich dann, dass sie aber dann so beschreibt, wie verrückt diese Rekrutierung in Russland ist, also wie die Wehrämter Bestechungsgelder kassieren und wer dort alles dann als kriegstauglich angesehen wird und wie man sich dem auch entziehen kann mit Geldzahlungen etc. In den Passagen muss man dann schon mal darüber reden, wie viele aus der Ukraine geflohen und desertiert sind. Man muss dann schon mal über die Zwangsrekrutierung in der Ukraine reden. Man müsste auch da mal über die Korruption beim ukrainischen Militär sprechen. Das ist einfach sonst halb gar. Wenn man jetzt einfach nur sagt, das machen die dann Russlandsohn, wir wundern uns, dann muss man das schon mal in eine gewisse Beziehung setzen.
Zumindest nennt sie die Zahlen und kommt kurz auf diesen Juli 25 als Zelensky, die Korruptionsbehörde da.
Ja, das nennt sie aber dann als so einen großen Tag. Zelensky wollte eigentlich da so einen Schritt gehen, wieder weg von Korruptionsbekämpfung. Dann gibt es eine Rebellion dagegen. Und das ist ein Zeichen dafür, wie lebendig die Demokratie ist. Ja, natürlich ist die Ukraine wesentlich demokratischer als Russland. Aber man kann ja jetzt nicht so tun, als seien das Freiwillige, die sich da zum Kriege melden und einfach gegen Russland kämpfen wollen. Und auf der anderen Seite schildert man so, wie da Zwangsrekrutierungen stattfinden auf russischer Seite. Da muss man schon beide Seiten mal darstellen, wie sich da verhält. Und da müsste man auch vielleicht mal sich zu äußern, wie das eigentlich mit einem demokratischen Impetus zusammenpasst, wenn da Menschen daran gehindert werden zu fliehen oder wenn sie Zwangsrekrutiert werden. Das bleibt sie alles schuldig.
Also ich finde auch, bei Zelensky ist sie ein bisschen zahm, oder sagen wir mal, die Zelensky Zeit.
Ja.
Zumindest vorher, Janukovic nennt sie 2010 bis 2014 in vier Jahren der geschätzte 100 Milliarden aus dem System rausgezogen für sich. Poroschenko wurde dann der Schokoladenkönig, besaß mehrere Waffenfirmen, Werften, Autohäuser und TV-Sender. In den Panama Papers wurde es dann enthüllt. Ja, und Zelenskis Aufstieg lief dann genau über im Fernsehen spielt er einen Lehrer, oder wie auch immer, der dann diesen Präsidenten eine Rede unterjubelt gegen die Korruption. Also sie zitiert ja dann kurz aus der Rede. Und ja, 2025 eben zum einen diese große Ermittlung. Später dann wissen wir ja, es gab wieder diesen Korruptionsskandal. Das eigene Kabinett ist ja zur Hälfte dadurch dezimiert worden. Und da ging es ja auch um 100 Millionen aus diesem laufenden Kriegsbetrieb, die da abgezweigt wurden. Ja, da würde ich auch sagen, so langsam ist das buchfällig, dass er uns erklärt, wie trotz aller Unmöglichkeit und Nullerklärung dieser Krieg immer noch läuft. Ja, also es ist echt ein Wunder.
Nochmal diese Argumentation, die sie dann zum Schluss ihrer Russland-Kapitel macht. Die Soldaten bekommen jetzt sehr viel Geld, viel mehr Geld, als sie sonst hätten in der freien Wirtschaft verdienen können. Deswegen gibt es da ein Anreiz. Wenn sie sterben, besonders werden also die Familien ausgestattet mit diesem Geld. Das fließt in die Wirtschaft. So wird das künstlich am Leben halten. Das ist ja auch richtig erklärt. Jetzt aber die Argumentation, die daraus folgt, ist für sie, dass Putin verstanden hat, dass es da keine Friedensdividende für ihn gibt, dass er also alle weiter kämpfen lässt. Und da erinnert er eigentlich an Napoleon oder Saddam Hussein, wo ich sage, naja, das sind schon andere Wirtschaftssysteme, über die wir dann da reden. Bei Hussein und bei Napoleon ist recht. Sie sagt dann, der Umbau von einer Kriegszufriedenswirtschaft würde ja dauern, falls er überhaupt gelingt. Die Ex-Soldaten und ehemaligen rüstungsbeschäftigten, würden aber sofort neue Jobs benötigen. Russland geriete in eine schwere Wirtschaftskrise, die sich nicht nur in den armen Regionen im fernen Sibirien auswirken würde. Auch in Moskau und St. Petersburg gab es viele arbeitslose Unmut in den Städten, kann jedoch gefährlich werden, wie schon die Zaren erleben mussten. Das ist jetzt also ihre Logik dafür, dass Putin einfach immer weiter Krieg führt, wenn wir gleich aber erfahren auch, dass Putin immer ärmer wird dadurch, dass Krieg geführt wird und dass das eigentlich lange nicht mehr am Leben zu halten ist. Warum soll es jetzt hier Proteste geben, wo das russische Volk ja interessanterweise, sie beschreibt es ja selbst, in den 90er Jahren sogar nicht rebelliert hat, sondern es waren da die Eliten, die sich gegen Jelzin stellten und deswegen Putin präferiert haben. Sie sagt dann selbst, schon jetzt meinen 70 Prozent der Russischen befragten, dass die USA und die NATO den Krieg in der Ukraine angezettelt hätten. Weitere 17 Prozent glauben, dass die Ukraine den Konflikt begonnen habe und nur 7 Prozent sehen die Schuld bei Russland. Das heißt ja doch ganz deutlich, es ist gar nicht ein Umsturz zu befürchten für Putin, sondern er hat ja offenbar die Mehrheit auf seiner Seite. Sie schreibt dann weiter, die NATO rechnet damit, dass Putin schon 2027 das Baltikum attackieren könnte, genug Soldaten hätte Putin, um weitere Kriege anzuzetteln. Zwar wurden in der Ukraine über eine Million russischer Kompatanten getötet oder verwundet, aber Putins Reservoir an wehrfähigen Männern ist noch längst nicht ausgeschöpft. Bisher hat er vor allem Minderheiten, Häftlinge, Söldner und Nordkoreaner in den Krieg geschickt und die ethnischen Russen in den Städten geschont, um keinen Widerstand zu provozieren. Aber diese Hemmungen könnte er fallen lassen und massiv mobilisieren. Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn. Also Putin, schreibt sie im Prinzip jetzt, erklärt sie uns, will weiter Krieg führen, um das russische Volk hinter sich zu einigen. Siehe Meinungsumfragen. Um also dann Krieg im Baltikum zu führen, also Krieg muss im Baltikum geführt werden, um diese Meinungsumfragen hinter sich zu haben. Um aber diese Kriege im Baltikum führen zu können, müsste er Zwangsrekrutierungen vornehmen, und zwar auch in den Städten bei den ethnischen Russen. Das wird ja aber doch gerade nicht auf Zustimmung bei der Bevölkerung dazu führen, wie sie ja gerade selbst sagt. Das könnte sein, dass das Widerstand produziert, weshalb Putin die ganze Zeit irgendwie Häftlinge, Söldner und sonst was nimmt. Also das bedeutet doch, dass sie hier eigentlich sagt, wir lenken mit einem Krieg ab. Aber wenn der Krieg dann im Baltikum geführt wird, muss ich Zwangsrekrutierungen vornehmen, was nicht zur Zustimmung bei der Bevölkerung führt, sondern Aufstände wahrscheinlicher macht, die Putin aber eigentlich ja durch die Kriege, laut Ulrike Herrmann, zu verhindern sucht. Wie soll das zusammengehen?
Also das geht natürlich gar nicht zusammen. Und ich würde sagen, wir sehen ja jetzt in Amerika, wie von heute auf morgen plötzlich in der publizierten Meinung so Sachen auftauchen, wie Alex Jones ist im Gespräch mit diesem Fuentes. Und sie jammern minutenlang darüber, dass sie dafür ja einen Nicht-Sign-up gemacht haben, dass wir jetzt im Iran-Krieg führen. Also es gibt sozusagen von jetzt auf gleich solche Umschwünge. Die schlagen sich natürlich irgendwo nieder. Und das kann man aber in Russland nicht beobachten, weil ja keiner so Podcasts macht. Und selbst wenn, wir können halt alle kein Russisch. Deshalb wird es hier einfach als unbeobachtbar. Und sie zieht jetzt irgendwelche Schlüsse aus irgendetwas, bei dem ich mir auch denke, naja, das will ich dann mal sehen, wenn in den russischen Vororten Rekrutierung stattfindet und mit weißen Mini-Bussen Männer von der Straße geholt werden, wie das dann aussieht.
Also jedenfalls wird das nicht...
Aber schließlich...
Man kann ja nicht beides tun. Man kann ja nicht sagen, man muss die Bevölkerung beruhigen, um sie abzulenken. Aber man lenkt sie ja nicht weiter ab, wenn man plötzlich mit Bussen vorfährt und junge Männer aus der Stadtbevölkerung zieht. Das geht ja nicht zusammen.
Also schöner, langer historischer Anlauf, der zu nichts führt. Überprüfen wir doch mal das China-Kapitel. Ja.
Die Rückkehr der Supermacht.
Genau. Und mit Rückkehr ist ja schon schwierig, dass sie, also sie stolpert ja selber wenn diese Merkwürdigkeiten. Rückkehr kann man durchaus sagen aus einem chinesischen Selbstverständnis, denn die hatten ja mal Supermachtsansprüche im Sinne von, dass sie heute in ihren eigenen Archiven lesen, wir haben ja diese Mauer nicht ohne Grund gebaut. Aber sie war auch eine Kehr nach innen. Die Flotten wurden abgerüstet, wie auch immer. Und dann hat China ein Jahrhundert der oder Jahrhunderte, aber zumindest ein für uns sehr interessantes Jahrhundert hingelegt, in dem, wie sie heute schreibt, nach der großen Veränderung der Welt 1989 konnte China aus dem Nichts schöpfen, musste also nicht etwas grob umbauen wie Russland, wodurch Bereicherung und Oligarchiesysteme etabliert wurden, sondern nein, die eine Partei konnte einfach sagen, das ist alles uns, niemand hat Widerstand gehabt, jetzt ist etwas da und die behaupten immer noch, das ist alles uns und es gibt auch weiterhin kein Widerstand. So, das passt aber nicht zu diesem, die Rückkehr der Supermacht, denn wir schließen ja gerade nicht an, an ein Supermachtsverständnis. Also schon in der Konzeption der, wie funktionieren diese Überschriften, also wirklich große Kapitelüberschriften mit der eigentlichen Pointe, die sie ja vorbereiten möchte, zum Titel des Buches, nur unschärfen. Ja, also das Lektorat ist genauso schlecht bei Bibi und bei Bibi muss man sagen, wurden einfach gar keine Absätze eingefügt in den Buch. Also es ist wirklich grotesk.
Ja, wie mächtig ist denn China? Sie geht da vor allem ins neunzete Jahrhundert zurück, erzählt noch mal die Geschichte des Opium Krieges. Alles ganz interessant. Da könnte man überlegen, kann man Ableitungen heute finden. Also ich würde ja dann noch sagen, wenn ich vom Opiumkrieg spreche, müsste ich dann über die Fentanyl-Krise sprechen heute. Wäre ja eine Idee, ob man da irgendeinen Bezug herstellen kann. Ich glaube, es trägt nicht wahnsinnig weiter, aber möglicherweise. Ich fand das jetzt auch wieder so sprunghaft. Also das, was man sich über China relativ schnell anlesen kann, wenn man sich ein bisschen dafür interessiert, dann kann man das hier noch mal vermittelt bekommen in konzentrierter Form. Es geht dann um natürlich Maos Herrschaft zum großen Sprung. Macht sie uns noch mal die Zahlen klar. Das ist ja doch ganz wichtig, sich das noch mal in Erinnerung zu rufen. Im Jahr 1958 rief Mao zum großen Sprung nach vorn aus, um auch die Landwirtschaft zu industrialisieren. Alle Bauernhöfe wurden in Kollektiven zusammengefasst, die aber keine zusätzlichen Mittel erhielten. Der Staat investierte nicht, sondern appellierte nur. Mao schien jedoch der eigenen Propaganda zu glauben, das enorme Ernten zu erwarten sein und verlangte von den neuen Kollektiven viel zu hohe Quoten. Vor dem großen Sprung nach vorn hatte der Staat im Durchschnitt 18,3 Prozent der Ernten abgeschöpft und in die Städte gelenkt. Aber mit dem Jahr 1959 wurden es plötzlich 28 Prozent. Ausgerechnet diese Ernte fiel jedoch besonders mage aus, sodass mindestens 16, möglicherweise aber auch mehr als 40 Millionen Bauern verhungerten. Diese selbst erzeugte Katastrophe erinnerte ebenfalls an Stalin. Ja, also das beschreibt sie, das Land ist bitterarm, es produziert Hungertote ohne Ende, es ist eine radikale Misswirtschaft, eine fehlerhafte Planung in Dimensionen, wie man sie sich nicht vorstellen kann eigentlich. Dann mit Maus tot.
Ja, also sie macht das, finde ich, auch ganz schlüssig. Diesen Bogenschlag aus während Kolumbus Amerika entdeckt und man von drei Schiffen und 87 Mann spricht, ist China mit, sie nennt hier Zhenghe, mit 317 Schiffen und Tausenden, Zehntausenden Mann auf den Seewegen unterwegs bis Afrika. Dann aber diese große Wende nach innen. Und 1976 ist das Land auf 5% pro Kopf Erträgen im Vergleich zu Amerika. Also es gibt sozusagen keine historische Hinterlassenschaft, keine Ausgangslage. Man ist einfach Battle, Battle, Battlearm. Und 1976. Also sozusagen im greifbaren Rahmen, wie wir es ja hier jetzt auch interessant finden.
Ja, Deng wird dann der neue Führer der kommunistischen Partei werden, wird also die Geschicke lenken. Da beschreibt sie dann kurz den Aufstieg Chinas. Also wir wissen, China öffnet sich dann. Es gibt dieses Treffen ja noch damals mit Mao und Nixon, aber dann mit Deng gibt also diese Öffnung hin zum Westen weiter. Sie spricht davon, dass es vor allem die technischen Möglichkeiten dann sind, die Deng in die Hände spielen. Das würde ich auch sagen, dass das ein Aspekt ist. Aber viel wichtiger und das erwähnt sie auch am Rande, sind natürlich die Möglichkeiten, es anders zu gestalten. Also man setzt auf Preiskontrollen. Das ist ja das große Buch zum Thema Inflation und China von Isabella Weber, das sie hier nur einmal zitiert. Das hätte man eigentlich weiter ausführen können. Man unterwirft sich dann in der Entwicklung auch nicht den Vorgaben der Austeritätspolitik. Wir wissen, wenn China dann Anfang der Nullerjahre der Welthandelsorganisation beitritt, also sich diesen Institutionen anschließt, dann geht man trotzdem weiterhin einen eigenen Weg, investiert also viel, viel stärker, um damit eigentlich eine andere Erfolgsgeschichte des Kapitalismus zu erzählen. Nämlich eine geplante Volkswirtschaft, die natürlich freie Konkurrenz kennt. Im Sinne von, da gibt es schon Wettbewerb zwischen den Regionen und zwischen den Unternehmen. Aber es gibt eben eine weiterhin sehr große Planung, einmal zentral von Peking gesteuert, aber dann auch in den einzelnen Regionen. Und man setzt sich also nicht für einfach immer mehr freien Markt und Privatisierung ein, sondern man geht durchaus davon aus, dass man weiterhin planen muss, nur eben in einer gezügelt kapitalistischen Weise.
Genau, man regiert unter Stalin und Mao, diesen Rückenschlag macht sie, bis unter die Bettdecke, bis ins Management der Firmen hinein. Man sagt ihnen, welche Geräte hier die Amerikaner machen, das so, mach mal so. Während Deng hier diese große Öffnung macht, zum einen das kapitalistische Prinzip der Gewinnmaximierung und so wird den Unternehmern mitgegeben, ohne ihnen konkret zu sagen, welche Maschine und so weiter. Ja, sondern man lässt ihnen so eine Managementfreiheit. Und sehr interessant, dasselbe für die Familien. Familien entscheiden selbst. Familien sind einer Profitlogik unterworfen. Der Staat möchte sich da konkret nicht mehr ein. Wir haben das damals in diesem Sammelband zum chinesischen Denken, in einem Text, den ich ja auch in der Kinderwiese dann zitiert habe, wo das ja aus dieser Zeit thematisiert wird. Und das ist wahnsinnig interessant, aber jetzt weder Thema dieses Buches noch sonstiges, aber trotzdem super interessant, dass China genau daran heute leidet, dass die Familien seit Deng unter ihr kümmert euch um die Rente. Es ist ja euer Großvater. Und jetzt lebt dieser Großvater aber bis 85 und nicht mehr bis 55. Und hat 15 Jahre Rente, die irgendwie erwirtschaftet werden muss. Weshalb diese gigantische Sparquote und dieses enorme Interesse auch der Privatleute, wir konsumieren jetzt nichts, wir kaufen uns das Haus im 17. Stock dieses großen Hauses und so weiter, denn entstehen für 30 Billionen Dollar solche Häuser. Und alle wollen das als Zukunftsinvestitionen für die Rente und so weiter. Und es klappt dann einfach nicht. Also das, was sie hier als den großen Erfolgsfaktor, muss man heute, da China eben keine Ein-Kind-Politik mehr macht, aber unter allen historischen Zahlen bei dem Nachwuchs liegt und so, muss man auch immer wieder dieses, die Familie, die Freiheit, die Politik mischt sich da nicht ein. Hier nicht begleitet von so einem sakralen Überbau, wie zeitgleich oder später dann bei, wie hieß unser großer Filmschauspieler, Amerikas Präsident Ronald Reagan, der ja auch sagte, die Familie ist heilig, da mischen wir uns nicht ein und so. Das kommt aus dieser Zeit damals in Deutschland und Europa. Dankenswerterweise, man hat den Sozialstaat durchgezogen. Selbst als es hieß, konnte man ja auch mal historisch jetzt neu bewerten, in Berlin regiert die Linke und sagt, wir bleiben mal dabei, die Sozialversicherung bleibt, wie sie ist. Wir verkaufen nur ein paar Wohnungen, die uns als Stadt gehören. Rückblickend heute natürlich, oh man, ihr habt diese Wohnung verkauft, aber wir hätten damals noch viel schlimmere Sachen machen können.
Das war so ein kleiner Ausverkauf. Russland hat einfach alles verschärbelt.
Genau, genau.
Das war so eine Mini-Variation.
Wir wissen ja auch, an wen wir die verkauft haben. Also die Wohnung für 3000 Euro, das Stück an Vonovia.
Hätten wir auch paar genommen, ja.
Kann man auch zurückkaufen.
Ulrike Herrmann ist ja durchaus als Keynesianerin zu verstehen. Sie hat deshalb auch sehr viel Sympathie für diese Entwicklung, die China genommen hat. Insofern, als sie schreibt, der Staat muss lenken und den Binnenmarkt abschotten, um die heimische Industrie zu entwickeln. Doch diesen Weg können nur noch sehr große Länder gehen, weil die neueste Technik riesige Fabriken und viele Kunden erfordert. Also das ist etwas, was uns erst einmal einleuchtet. China hat also diese Möglichkeit gehabt.
Momentchen mal, haben wir nicht dieses Esra Kleinbuch gelesen, in dem das als aktuelle Forderung formuliert wird?
Für große Länder, für große Länder.
Und du fandest es aber auch für Amerika nicht so die treffende Analyse?
Nein, Moment. Hier geht es ja um das Aufsteigen eines Landes. Und der Aufstieg, also Amerika steigt ja jetzt nicht erstmal auf.
Ja, aber sie könnten ja wieder aufsteigen.
Na ja, sie sind ja momentan Spitze.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, dass sie militärisch und finanziell, aber industriell nicht so unbedingt super spitze sind.
Das bezieht sich ja auf eine Diskussion, die haben wir auch gesehen bei Patrick Kaczmarczyk. Wenn Entwicklungsländer da sind und sich einfach nur unterjochen müssen, dem IDF und so weiter, dann müssen sie ja sagen, wir müssen sparen. Wir sparen sogar an der Bildung, damit wir irgendwelche Auflagen bei Schuldenquoten erfüllen. Wichtig ist aber zu erkennen, und wir öffnen uns dem Freihandel und all das, und wichtig ist aber zu erkennen, dass wenn man sich historisch die Entwicklung ansieht von industriellen Ländern heute, dann haben die eigentlich das gemacht, was man nennt, schlag die Leiter hinter dir weg, also steig nach oben auf einen protektionistischen Weg. Ja, klau auch zum Beispiel urheberrechtlich geschütztes aus anderen Ländern. Mach all das. Und wenn du dann oben bist, dann kannst du die Leiter umdrehen und sagen, ihr braucht unbedingt Freihande. Das ist ganz wichtig für euch. Und das ist hier diese Erzählung, die Ulrike Herrmann zwar nicht direkt zitiert, soweit ich das in Erinnerung habe, aber die sie zumindest aufgreift. Und das kann ich auf jeden Fall nachvollziehen, dass so die Entwicklungen gewesen sind. Was ich dann aber nicht verstehe, ist, wenn sie dann zu Xi Jinping kommt und auch dessen Geschichte mal so herleitet, also wie bei Putin, der wir wissen, wie der Vater gedemütigt wird von dem Maoistischen Regime, wie er dann zigmal versucht, in die Partei zu kommen, aufgenommen zu werden.
Irgendwann schafft er es.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Tagesthemen. Und die übergehen wir hier komplett. Und dann dabei herauszukommen, auch wieder bei so einem Fazit, wie wir das schon bei Putin gesehen haben, 1,4 Milliarden Chinesen hängen vom Willen eines einzelnen Mannes ab. Sie sind Xi ausgeliefert und müssen darauf vertrauen, dass er die richtigen Entscheidungen trifft. Das, möchte ich sagen, stimmt so nicht ganz. Wir haben diese auf Xi ausgerichtete, autoritäre Struktur im Staat. Aber wir sehen ja gerade aufgrund der Größe des Landes und aufgrund des regionalen Wettbewerbs, dass es natürlich innerhalb dieser Partei eine Binnenpluralität gibt, die nicht vergleichbar ist mit dem, was in Russland passiert. Diese Binnenpluralität meint jetzt nicht, da ist eigentlich Demokratie. Das will ich damit nicht gesagt haben. Aber es ist gerade nicht nur ausgerichtet auf eine Person, die quasi das ganze Land in dem Sinne regiert und sagt, wir machen dies und das, sondern man hat ja gerade damit eine gewisse Behaarungskraft hergestellt, dass man diese Wettbewerbsmechanismen hat, dass man die widerstreitenden Interessen da auch hat. Und das sehen wir ja dann auch. Adam Tooze hat das ja in den Podcasts immer wieder beschrieben, dass es da zum Beispiel Tendenzen gibt, die eher zu einer Austeritätspolitik neigen in der Partei. Und andere wiederum sagen, wir müssen eigentlich noch mehr investieren für die Erneuerbaren. Also auch da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansätze. Das heißt, wir haben es da schon mit einer komplexeren Regierung zu tun, als das mit Putin und seinen Oligarchen der Fall ist.
Es gibt hier eine Anmerkung zu machen, weil du ja mal darüber sprachst, dass ja Niklas Lumans Theorie aus einer Zeit kam, in der es relativ stabil war. Und ich will hier noch mal anmerken, habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht, Putins politische Soziologie zum Thema Bindifferenzierung, Regierung, Opposition und dann ein Machtkreislauf über das Publikum, das da immer wieder mit reinfunkt, wird in seiner eigenen Ausarbeitung nicht an Parteien, was man ja denken könnte, wenn man so in den 70er, 80er, 90er Jahren das so schreibt, sondern es gibt sogar eine Anmerkung von ihm zu sagen, naja, also Regierung, Opposition, es muss halt einen Wechsel, eine Oszillation geben. Die wäre aber auch möglich in, das sieht man ja in Stadtparlamenten wie in Frankfurt, jeder Magistrat soll sich seine Mehrheit selbst suchen, weil es gerade keine Regierungskoalition gibt. So, also zieht jeder los und sucht sich Mehrheiten unter den 93 Anwesenden. Oder aber, und dann, das müsste man mal diskutieren, ob in China nicht genauso, wie Adam Tooze das immer wieder betont, das Wechselspiel aus Regierung und Opposition sichtbar, also wirklich sichtbar ist, würde man sich diese Politbüro-Diskussion und so weiter da anschauen. Wir kriegen natürlich immer nur diese Schauseite zu sehen, in der einfach verkündet wird, drei Stunden lang, was jetzt mal wieder. Aber die Renkelspiele vorher, wie Adam Tooze sagt, da gibt es echte Politik. Man muss es sich nur angucken. Von daher würde ich eben auch sagen, dass sie hier einfach wieder, weil sie ja schon im Putin-Kapitel oder im Russland-Kapitel, auf Geschichte, Geschichte, Geschichte Putin. Und jetzt kommt sie hier wieder mit Geschichte, Geschichte, Geschichte Xi. Da würde ich auch sagen, das kann man so nicht machen. Das ist einfach ein bisschen zu sehr wieder dieser Tagesthemen-Logik. Und da geht eigentlich das Interessante verloren aus dem Blick.
Sie schreibt, Xi strebt die Autarkie an, weil er im Kriegsfall in der Lage sein möchte, sanktionen wirkungslos zu machen. Doch eine echte Entkopplung ist der chinesischen Wirtschaft bisher nicht gelungen. 2015 entsprachen Exporte und Importe zusammen, etwa 39,5 Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung. 2023 lag dieser Wert bei noch 37,3 Prozent. China ist und bleibt ein Teil der Weltwirtschaft. Manche Importe lassen sich ohnehin nicht ersetzen. Vor allem Nahrungsmittel, Öl, Gas und andere Rohstoffe sind für die chinesische Wirtschaft essenziell. Um diesen Güterstrom zu sichern, hat Xi bereits 2013 ein einzigartiges Projekt gestartet, die Neue Seidenstraße. Das ist doch ein Widerspruch. Sie kann doch nicht den Absatz beginnen, mit Xi strebt nach Autarkie, also nach Unabhängigkeit, um dann zu sagen, 2013 gab es ein neues Projekt, die Neue Seidenstraße. Also es ist ja kein Projekt der Autarkie, sondern es ist ja eines der Vernetzungen. Xi will nicht autark werden im Sinne von ich löse mich vom Export. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie das her hat, weil das Exportmodell ist doch das, was China jetzt gerade vorantreibt, weshalb ja es diese Zollpolitik seitens der EU und seitens der USA gibt, um gerade das nicht zu ermöglichen, dass China sich weiter mit der Welt vernetzt. Und die Abhängigkeit von Öl und Gas ist noch da gewiss, aber gerade deshalb setzt man ja auf eine erneuerbare Energie. Da hätte man tatsächlich dann Energieautarkie, weshalb ja die These von Tooze, noch einmal nennen wir ihn ja, ist, dass Amerika mit dieser nachhaltigen Politik, mit Klimazielen und so weiter, durchaus nicht grün war deshalb, weil das eine Bedrohung ist, weil plötzlich Länder autark werden in Sachen Energie. Also das stimmt alles doch so nicht.
Könnte man jetzt sagen, sie möchte eine analytische Autarkie-Definition im Sinne von der Made in China 2025 Schlüsseltechnologien strebt man eine Autarkie an. Also selbst herstellen möchte man E-Autos, Solartechnik, Batterien, Telekommunikation, Schiffbau, Bahntechnik, da hat man es schon geschafft. Man ist ja der größte Bahnhersteller der Welt, aber hat noch nie einen Zug exportiert zum Beispiel. Das sind ja so interessante Sachen. Aber offen sind noch Mikrochips, Verkehrsflugzeuge, Biomedizin und Werkzeugmaschinen. Nur, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, wie man als Ökonomin darauf zu sprechen kommen kann, hier diese Art von Herstellerkapitalismus ohne Konsumenten zu denken, weil China braucht jetzt die Welt, um das zu verkaufen. Gerade als deutsche Ökonomin, weil wir Europäer haben ja nun allerbeste Erfahrung damit, dass das gerade nicht auf Autarkien ausläuft. Ich erinnere an diesen interessanten Text, den ich mal angesprochen hatte, in dem verglichen wird, warum ist Nordkorea so arm und Belgien so reich? Und warum erkennt man Belgien so wenig und Nordkorea? Da weiß man immer genau, dass man gerade in Nordkorea ist, weil diese Autarkie eben arm macht. Und genau das hat Chia und das Politbüro, soweit die Renkespiele da sind, verstanden, weil da ziehen zumindest alle an einem Strang. Es gibt jetzt gerade keine Bewegung, eine neue chinesische Mauer zu bauen und China ein zweites Mal, wie im 15. Jahrhundert von der Welt, abzukoppeln. Sondern es ist genau nicht diese Autarkiebestrebung. Hätte man das ein bisschen entfaltet, hätte sie das auch selber reinschreiben können. Von daher bleibt deine Verwunderung da völlig zurecht. Und es ist auch total albern. Und das ist aber wiederum, finde ich, eine deutsche Spezialart, Kapitalismus immer ohne Konsumenten zu beschreiben. Weshalb es Lars Feld auch so einfach fällt, zu sagen, Rentner brauchen doch kein Geld. Und dann kommt man mit, ja, aber die Unternehmen brauchen doch Kunden. Nee, darüber reden wir ja nicht. Also, den Rentner müssen wir jetzt kein Geld geben. Die verkonsumieren das ja nur. So, und das ist halt der deutsche Diskurs.
Verkonsumieren das nur.
Ja. Die geben das nur aus.
Man müsste eigentlich mal mit dieser Haltung in Unternehmen gehen und sagen, ja, sie produzieren ja nur Waren für den Konsum. Also, das ist ja unsinnig.
Warum machen sie denn das? Wieso investieren sie nicht alles? Sie müssen ja nur noch in Maschinen investieren. Sie stellen Sachen her. Das ist cool.
Das wird doch eh nur konsumiert.
Aber das ist ihre Denke hier.
Ja. Dann die Idee, Xi sitzt in der Falle, wie Putin ja auch. Da haben wir schon gelernt. Auch in Zukunft wird die chinesische Wirtschaft nicht ausreichend wachsen, um Millionen Menschen jenen Aufstieg zu ermöglichen, der die Macht der kommunistischen Partei bisher legitimiert hat. Für Xi wäre es daher reizvoll, von den ökonomischen Problemen abzulenken, indem er den chinesischen Nationalismus bedient, der seit Jahrzehnten propagandistisch geschürt wird. Ein Eingriff auf Taiwan ist nicht unwahrscheinlich. Also wieder diese Logik. Wieso sollte Xi jetzt auf die Idee kommen, ich mache das, um abzulenken? Die These ist ja hier doch wieder so, dass man dann sagt, ja und dann gucken 1,4 Milliarden Chinesen stolz nach Taiwan, was dort die Armee so alles für Heldentatenvölk bringt und sagt, deswegen sind wir jetzt damit zufrieden, dass wir nicht aufsteigen. Also das ist ja hier die Logik, die es gibt. Und dann erzählt sie nochmal so die Situation von Taiwan.
Also was es auf jeden Fall gibt, ist ja dieser neue chinesische Egoismus, noch weit über Nationalismus hinaus.
Beides gibt es Nationalismus.
Und er wird ja sehr gefördert durch Xi macht da so ein Museum auf, der chinesische Soldat im zweiten Weltkrieg und dann stehen da so Wachsfiguren rum und das gucken sich dann Leute an. In den Nachrichten wird ja auch mittlerweile gezeigt, welche Seemanöver man macht. Aber das läuft ja alles unter der Maxime, wie bei Maga. Wir haben die beste Armee der Welt, wir sind die stärksten. Wir haben das Naval irgendwas, Team Six und so weiter. Dann gibt es diese Fernsehserie, das noch mal verherrlicht und so, ja. Während gleichzeitig die öffentliche Meinung sagt, er bittet bloß keinen Krieg. Ja, also wir wollen auf gar keinen Fall in irgendwelche kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen die Forever Wars. Wir haben genug davon. So und das passt offensichtlich nicht zusammen. Und ich finde, wenn wir auf Amerika gucken, ist es gerade am interessantesten, sich genau diesen Spaltpilz anzuschauen, der eben dann aufploppt, wenn, aber das ist dann eben wirklich tagesaktuell zu beobachten. Iran wird angegriffen, Alex Jones macht einen Podcast und plötzlich springt seine Viewerschaft wieder von 500.000 auf 5 Millionen. So, da ist also irgendwas da. Nur dafür muss man sich halt interessieren. Und dann muss man sich auch darauf fokussieren. Und genau das passiert nicht, wenn wir China immer von außen in diesem Panorama, also wir sehen die Manöver, wir sehen die Propaganda, neu jetzt kommen diese Filme. Aber daraus den Schluss zu ziehen, dass deswegen Taiwan jetzt wirklich angegriffen wird, da wäre ich ganz vorsichtig und ich möchte noch mal von vorhin.
Taiwan wird wenn auf jeden Fall aus einem anderen Grund angegriffen und nicht um Umfragewerte zu steigern.
Wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit steigt, dass Taiwan angegriffen wird, dann weil das Vorbild Trump es gerade vormacht.
Ja und weil es ein geopolitisches Interesse gibt und Xi offenbar der Ansicht wäre, dann wäre man militärisch abgesichert gegen USA.
Genau und weil sich und das wissen wir, die Chinesen sehr dafür interessieren, wie wir uns mit unserer öffentlichen Meinung zu den Sachen verhalten. Und wenn wir das jetzt bei Trump nicht verurteilen, ist das die eigentliche Gefahr für Taiwan. Nicht die Stärke Chinas, weil da ist doch völlig klar, dass die das von jetzt auf gleich und dass das auch wirklich nur ein Blitzkrieg wäre, weil die Insel ist nun mal klein.
Trump ist quasi der Türöffner dafür. Er ist der Gewährleister. Der hat das auch gemacht, dann können wir das auch machen. Sie widerspricht sich ja dann wenige Seiten später, wenn sie sagt, eine Vollinvasion, also Chinesische gegen Taiwan, wäre heikel. Durch die Ein-Kind-Politik, jetzt kommt deine Argumentation, die hier schon vor Jahren gebracht hast, hat jede chinesische Familie nur maximal einen Sohn. Sollten allzu viele chinesische Soldaten in einem Taiwan-Krieg sterben, dürfte nicht nur Xi seine Macht verlieren, es wäre auch das Ende der kommunistischen Partei. Also aus dieser Argumentation könnte ich ja sagen, also auf keinen Fall wird Xi Taiwan angreifen, wegen, ich habe es gerade ausgeführt. Aber nein, sie geht dann in diese anderen Argumentationen weiter. Also das ist höchst widersprüchlich. Xi's Risiko ist erheblich. Revolutionen sind oft durch verlustreiche Kriege ausgelöst worden. Bedeutet ja eigentlich die Revolutionstunde kurz bevor dort und in Russland müsste sie auch schon bald sein. Also was denn nun?
Ja, in diesem, was du jetzt referiert hast, steckt nicht nur Widerspruch, sondern auch eine gigantische Pointe. Denn sie kommt ja auf dieses, also ihr Problem, das sie behandelt, ist ja, sie möchte unbedingt uns Länder beschreiben und dann sagen, warum die jetzt unbedingt Krieg führen. Und wir versuchen jetzt Schritt für Schritt ihr zu sagen, nee, das macht irgendwie keinen Sinn und hier passt es auch wieder nicht. Ja, es ist noch viel drastischer, denn wenn sie jetzt nicht nur so ein Protagonistentheater, wie wir es aus den Tagesthemen machen, kennen, machen würde, sondern wirklich strukturell, die Kennziffer, die sie selber nennt, also die haben kein Rentensystem, es sind 400 Millionen arme Leute. Im Nachwuchs zwei Eltern, vier Großeltern, nur ein Kind. Das ist ja die Realität. So, darin steckt die gigantische Pointe. Wenn Xi den Binnenmarkt ankurpeln wollen würde, vielleicht als letzte Ressource für, okay, ich muss ihnen ein bisschen mehr Freiheit geben, dafür kriege ich Stabilität. Vielleicht auch nur für meine restlichen zehn Jahre Lebenszeit oder sowas, die sich der inzwischen auch schon ein 70-jährige, oder was weiß ich, wie alt er ist, Xi da gönnt, müsste er ein Rentensystem einführen. Denn wenn die Leute die staatlich garantierte Sicherheit bekämen, dass man sich nicht mit, wir müssen 30 Prozent unseres gegenwärtigen Einkommens weglegen, damit die Oma, die andere Oma, der Opa und die Mutter was davon hat später, sondern einfach klar wäre, Xi steht dafür, die kriegen alle ihre Grundrente, es ist alles geregelt. Dann könnten die jungen Familien so richtig rausgehen in die Welt. Eine Wohnung für sich kaufen, sich ein zweites Kind zutrauen, was auch immer. Und das ist aber genau die gegenteilige Argumentation zu Abenteuer Taiwan. Sondern man müsste jetzt wirklich, es ist im Grunde der Bismarck-Moment, der da offen ist. Einfach zu sagen, wir gründen jetzt ein, wir machen jetzt echte Sozialpolitik. Und das steht aber aus. Dafür, dass China immer so als, das ist ein kommunistisches Land und so, finde ich, ist das sowieso nochmal eine Paarte, die man eh mal ausformulieren muss. Denn wenn ein Land hardcore kapitalistisch ist, und zwar elementar, dann China. Ja, noch weit mehr als Amerika.
Wir, würde ich sagen, können über die nächsten beiden Kapitel ein bisschen schneller hinweggehen. Sie hat dann so ein Kapitel zu Atombombe, in dem sie nochmal so beschreibt, was die kann oder macht oder soll. Und das Atomkrieg auch gar keinen Sinn ergibt, weil das am Ende immer Selbstmord ist. Ich finde dann doch das ein bisschen fadlässig, dass sie nicht mal näher darauf eingeht, was da mit Schulz und Biden war. Denn das haben wir ja schon sehr gut auch jetzt von anderen gehört und können da so von ausgehen, dass das tatsächlich diese Gefahr bestand. Und für sie ist das aber so, naja, dann hat der Putin gedroht. Aber wo würde das schon hinführen? Also in den Selbstmord. So als wäre das quasi bei Schulz und Biden gar nicht so... Also sie, ich will es mal deutlich machen. Sie schreibt, der besten habe bei der Unterstützung der Ukraine bestenfalls halbherzig gehandelt, nur wegen Putins Atomwaffen-Drohung. Und da, also sie will eigentlich mit diesem Kapitel sagen, ich paraphrasiere das jetzt mal, lasst euch doch nicht ins Boxhorn jagen. Es hat noch immer Jod hier gehangen. Also ich finde das wirklich ein bisschen irre.
Da würde ich auch sagen, wir wissen, wir haben jetzt einen Kamini-Moment festhalten.
Ja.
Einige, und wir wissen es immer erst zu spät, sind bereit zu sterben.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Und nachdem ich, wie gesagt, nochmal diesen irren Putin hier porträtiert bekommen habe, weiß ich nicht. Ja.
Ich bin weiterhin Anhänger der Idee von Christoph Heusgen. Die sind zu Corona alle irre geworden.
Ja.
Das muss jetzt eingepreist werden. Von daher, ich finde auch das Atombomben-Kapitel, und ich habe ja selber gesagt, ich wünsche mir Atombomben und so. Und Macron will jetzt neue bauen, was ich auch super interessant finde, weil das bedeutet ja Fabrikation und nicht nur Restauration und so. Interessant.
Ja, ja. Man kann ja auch mal sich selbst fragen, würde man sich selbst zutrauen, den roten Knopf zu Hause zu haben? Ja, genau. Also wir wissen ja schon, Waffen zu Hause erhöhen nicht nur Mordrate, sondern auch Suizidrate. Mit der Atombombe können wir nochmal darüber reden. Wirtschaft als Waffe, dann kommt das plötzlich. Dann gibt es so ein bisschen Ölembargo, Schattenflotte, wie das so gelaufen ist. Die Bilanz ist also für sie gemischt. Die Sanktionen gegenüber Russland haben was bewirkt, aber sie haben natürlich nicht so viel bewirkt, wie man sich dachte. Sie beschreibt, wie das Tricksen da geht über Aserbaidschan. Sie beschreibt dann auch diese Konflikte zwischen China und den USA, um seltene Erden. Das ist aber einfach so ein bisschen reportiert, was der aufmerksame Zeitungsleser so in den letzten Monaten mitbekommen hat. Da weiß ich auch gar nicht, wohin das jetzt gerade führt. Sie wundert sich auch so ein bisschen, dass zwar Deutschland jetzt sich von China mehr lösen will, aber BASF und so weiter investieren ja dennoch kräftig. Da würde ich sagen, ja, Elle, wo ist denn die, wo ist die Alternative? Im Kapitel zu NATO heißt es dann viel Geld, wenig Waffen. Also man ist eigentlich doch finanziell ganz gut ausgestattet, aber man hat viel zu wenige Waffen. Und auch da springt sie aber dann mal so durch die verschiedenen Waffensysteme durch. Erzählt noch mal, wie das ist bei Top Gun. Aber auch die Star Wars können uns immer mehr drohen. Sie meldet, vermeldet da eigentlich dann so verschiedene Entwicklungen der letzten Monate und Jahre. Nicht genügend Soldaten gibt es jedenfalls. Sie schreibt dann auch wie in dieser Serie, Explorers Influencer die Bundeswehr als Abenteuerspielplatz inszenieren. Aber sie hofft, dass es dann doch so eine Art Wehrpflicht, irgendwie so ein schwedisches Modell, irgendwas, auf sowas wird es dann rauslaufen.
Ja, also das sind halt Kapitel, die so ein bisschen darunter leiden, dass sie diese ganzen Kennziffern halt einfach auf Abruf hat. Aber das erwarte ich ehrlich gesagt von jedem Sachbuchschreiber heute, dass Kennziffern einfach auf Abruf breit liegen, und man da nicht mehr, also die Rechercheleistung kann ja jeder selber machen. Wie viel Gramm seltene Erden pro Megawatt so Windkraftanlage und so, sowas erfahren wir dann. Ich finde, ab Gefahren der Globalisierung wird es wieder interessant. Denn China, die sich nun so ein bisschen raushalten aus dem Sanktionsregime gegen Russland, weil sie da erstens billig Energie kaufen können und zweitens einen Absatzmarkt finden, bei dem sie ein bisschen diktieren können. Also man muss dann halt Taschenrechner für so und so viel kaufen, weil es gibt keine anderen. So, und jetzt kommt aber das Verhältnis China-Amerika zur Sprache. Im Dezember 2024 hält China 915 Milliarden Dollar in Form von Staatsanleihen. Was zum einen bedeutet, das Geld fehlt Amerika nicht, weil die können ja Geld selber drucken, haben wir ja vielfach thematisiert. Es wäre aber durchaus problematisch für Amerika, wenn jetzt plötzlich 900 Milliarden auf dem Devisenmarkt auftauchen. Und quasi das, was ja immer gerne ist, Inflation und der ganze Kram, was da drüber so. Wenn man das ad hoc macht, kann man das hier, würde ich sagen, durchaus als Waffe einsetzen. Wird aber von ihr nur als Känze vergenannt, nicht durchdiskutiert. Aber sie weiß kurz daraufhin, dass beim Gold ein neues chinesisches Interesse da ist. Also ein Trend seit Frühjahr 2022. Man kauft jetzt Gold und man weiß nicht genau, wie viel. Denn offiziell besitzt China 2.300 Tonnen Gold. In Wahrheit könnte es auch doppelt so viel sein.
Ja, Christin Lagarde hat das ja auch in uns wieder angemerkt. Wir hatten irgendwann mal so eine Rede von ihr und dann sagte sie, ja, das mit der Entdolarisierung könnte vielleicht allmählich, aber dann rapide passieren.
Also das ist ja was, wir haben ja diese Texte gelesen, aus den etwas klügeren Richtungen, die diese Strategie formulieren zum Thema, ja ja, wir haben diese Schusskraft und wir haben den Dollar, aber wir haben keine Industriegrundlage und damit fehlt uns jetzt eins von drei Beinen, damit der Tisch sicher steht. Und das bedeutet eben, dass mit diesem zweiten Bein Finanzierung alles muss über Dollar abgewickelt werden, ist halt auch wackeliger. So deswegen brauchen wir wieder diesen dritten, das dritte Bein oder wir bauen ein viertes. Die Welt bezahlt uns dafür, dass wir sehwegefrei schießen. Also dieses Austarieren, ja. Und wenn man dann solche Zahlen hier liest mit. Also zum einen haben die ganz schön viele Dollarreserven, die man ad hoc auf den Markt schmeißen kann, wenn man selber darauf verzichten kann, was die Chinesen super können. Also sag ich jetzt mal so flapsig, aber die Amerikaner müssten dann schon eingreifen und gleichzeitig noch diese Bedrohung über Gold. Wir sehen ja, wie attraktiv Gold gerade ist. Also diese Reserven, die man da angehäuft hat, die sind ja allein im letzten Jahr irgendwie um 30 Prozent gestiegen und so. Also damit kann man ja wirklich Einfluss auf nicht nur den Markt nehmen, sondern auf Marktteilnehmer nehmen, die gerade sehr verunsichert sind und sich dafür entschieden haben, dass für sie erstmal nur Gold zählt. Und jetzt hat China plötzlich so viele im Angebot. Also da kann man ja schon Nadelstiche setzen, würde ich mal so grob sagen. Aber leider diskutiert sich das nicht aus. Aber falls jemand Texte kennt dazu, das wäre durchaus interessant.
Ja, es gibt ja eine Debatte über diese Entdolarisierung, ob es sie gibt, was das in Bezug auf Gold bedeutet. In der Financial Times gibt es ja ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze, weil wirklich sich die Top-Ökonomenschaft da sehr uneins ist. Was sie zu den jungen Männern jetzt hierzulande zu sagen hat, ist das Folgendes, viele junge Männer fürchten, schon bald in einen Krieg ziehen zu müssen, wenn sie sich jetzt als Berufssoldat oder Wehrdienstleistende zur Armee melden. Das ist verständlich. Doch tatsächlich funktioniert die Logik genau anders herum. Ein Konflikt wird weniger wahrscheinlich, wenn der Westen seine Truppen aufstockt und auf Abschreckung setzt. Je mehr Soldaten die NATO aufbieten kann, desto geringer ist das Risiko, dass Russland überhaupt einen Angriff wagt.
Aber hatte sie das eben nicht noch andersherum erklärt? Die Chinesen haben so viel, damit sie angreifen können und wir haben so viel, damit wir nicht angreifen können?
Moment, du gehst ja fast davon aus, als würde jemals von einem westlichen Land aus ein Krieg begonnen werden. Das gibt es natürlich nicht. Wir sind nur defensiv. Also dieses ganze Buch ist ja wirklich so da, dass wir eigentlich in einer Buddehaltung da sitzen und wir gar nicht wissen, wie uns geschieht. Und jetzt ereignet sich Weltgeschichte und wir als rein passive Subjekte müssten vielleicht doch die Kraft aufbringen, dann wenigstens zu reagieren, dass wir agieren. Ich meine, dieses Buch ist jetzt schon schlecht gealtert, allein durch Trumps Angriffe, die da gefahren werden. Und ich meine, wir hatten schon nach dem 7. Oktober, nachdem Israel dann auch begann, Gaza zu bombardieren, Ideen von Roderich Kiesewetter, dass man zur Not auch Bundeswehrsoldaten braucht, denn das gehört zur Staatsräson dazu. Wir haben Aussagen gehabt, hier gespielt im Podcast, glaube ich sogar zweimal von der Lage der Nation. Da müssen wir zur Not die Huttis in die Steinzeit zurückkommen.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, ja.
Wenn das jetzt mit den Ölpreisen so weitergeht, haben wir schon von der Wirtschaftsministerin gehört. Sie wird daran nichts ändern mit einer Preispolitik oder so. Aber möglicherweise kommen die auf die Idee, da müssen wir irgendwo mal wieder was freischießen, damit das Öl wieder fließt. Das heißt also, so zu tun, als sei Deutschland oder Europa so vollkommen defensiv und würde einfach nur sich aufrusten, damit wenn Russland auf Ideen kommt, merkt, ach nee, wir sind ja hier abgeschreckt durch die. Mal davon abgesehen, dass diese Rüstungsspirale ja so immer weitergeht und es diesen Punkt ja nicht gibt, an dem man sagt, ach so, jetzt geht es gerade nicht. Es ist eigenartig, noch eigenartiger finde ich allerdings, dass sie dann auf den letzten acht Seiten einmal auf das Klima zu sprechen kommt und sagt, ja, Militär verbraucht schon einiges, nämlich ist für 5,5 Prozent der Treibhausgase verantwortlich, schon jetzt, also eh die ganz große Aufrüstung beginnt. Aber sie sagt dann auch, ist gar nicht so schlimm, denn dieses Geld, das dafür jetzt mobil gemacht würde, das würde ja sonst für was anderes ausgegeben werden. Und dadurch würden ja auch Treibhausgase entstehen. Und dann würde ich sagen, nee, man könnte es in Bildung investieren, man könnte es in Erneuerbare investieren und würde genau nicht mehr, sondern weniger Treibhausgasemissionen haben. Sie hat dann noch schließlich so eine Keynesianische Idee, so eine Hoffnung. Die Ukraine ist zwar schwer zerstört, aber hat großes Potenzial im Krieg, hat sich gezeigt, wie innovativ die Ukrainer sind. Innerhalb von wenigen Jahren entwickelten sie Drohnen- und Marschflugkörper, die den westlichen Waffen überlegen sind. Denn die Ukraine kann auf eine breite Schicht heimischer Ingenieure und Informatiker zurückgreifen. Vor dem Krieg lebten allein in Kiew mehr als 300.000 IT-Spezialisten und pro Jahr schlossen in der Ukraine 130.000 Ingenieure ihr Studium ab. Was sie jetzt hofft, ist, dass Europa sich gemeinschaftlich massiv für die Ukraine verschuldet, um dort ein blühendes Land nach ihrer kinesianischen Industriepolitik, so wie sie sich das vorstellt, umzusetzen. Und das würde dann auch die Einigung Europas vorantreiben. Es sind diese militärischen Zwänge jetzt gerade, die eine Einheit bringen. Neben der Wirtschaft wird nun auch die Verteidigung, ihre Finanzierung gemeinsam organisiert. Siehst du gerade, dass Europa sich aufeinander zubewegt? Du hast jetzt gerade noch gesagt, jetzt kracht es auch zwischen März und Makron schon in Sachen Iran. Woher entnimmt man diese Infos?
Also ich glaube Europas bisherige Schwäche, dass wir alle unterschiedliche Sprachen sprechen, ist gerade eine Stärke. Ansonsten hätten wir ein Leitartikel nach dem anderen gegen Sanchez. Aber keiner spricht Spanisch, also das ist gut. Ja. Sonst würde das auffallen.
Ja.
Und von daher hast du absolut recht. Und ihre Pointe ist ja auch ein bisschen, also ich bin ja auch ein großer Anhänger von Eurobonds und so. Ich habe auch gesagt, also dass man das während Corona gemacht hat, ist voll gut. Nur wir haben ja eine sehr schlimme Geschichte kürzlich geschrieben. Ich erinnere an den 6. November 2023, nee, 24. Donald Trump wird gewählt und die deutsche Regierung zerfliht. Und man sagt, Christian Lindner und so weiter hat hier keinen Schaden vom Land abgewendet. Und das hat ja genau damit zu tun, dass wir, und das war eigentlich meine Hoffnung, Eurobonds machen können für einen Kriegsfall, die wir danach einfach umwidmen. Aber deutsche Verfassungsrechtssprechung ist, wenn man für Corona eine Staatsverschuldung nimmt, darf man die danach nicht fürs Klima umwandeln, weil das Klima ist ja keine allgemeine Katastrophe, die zu bewältigen ist. Und von daher würde ich sagen, wenn wir diese Gelder nicht umwidmen dürfen, dann für den Krieg auch nicht aufnehmen. Also ich widerspreche genau ihre Schlussproante, dass Putin Europa spalten wollte und jetzt ein Eurobonds-gefestigtes, man hat genug Geld, nur noch keine Waffen, die kann man jetzt endlich kaufen und so. Und ich sage, nee, das ist nicht meine Denke und ich möchte auch nicht, dass andere Leute so denken.
Zum Schluss noch eine Frage. Du hast ja zwei Bücher geschrieben, die thematisch miteinander zusammenhängen. Familie und Kinder. Leuchtet ein. Es wäre jetzt eigenartig, wenn du in dem einen Buch was völlig anderes sagst wie in dem anderen. Wir haben von ihr gelesen, das Ende des Kapitalismus und dass das unabdingbar ist, dass wir uns jetzt gesund schrumpfen. Wir brauchen auch gar nicht auf technische Innovation groß zu hoffen, sondern wir müssen jetzt runter vom Gas und müssen wirtschaftlich ganz klar BIP schrumpfen. Wir haben jetzt hier ein Buch, in dem nur die ganze Zeit BIPs miteinander verglichen werden, Produktivität, Effizienz, alles wird die ganze Zeit durchgerechnet, wer jetzt gerade der stärkste ist, plus wir brauchen erhebliche Aufrüstung, um noch stärker zu werden. Ich kriege das nicht zusammen. Also sagt man jetzt einfach, das ist jetzt nochmal so ein Zwischenschritt in der Geschichte, bis Putin und Xi aufgeben und danach dort liberale Demokratien sind und dann machen wir die Kurse?
Ja, ich verstehe deinen Punkt. Also Markus Gabriel war im Alles gesagt Podcast sechs Stunden lang.
Hast du das echt gehört?
Ich habe mir die ersten zwei Stunden angehört, weil irgendwann redet er bestimmt nochmal über KI, das interessiert mich dann. Die ersten zwei Stunden sind einfach Verherrlichung der Biografie von Markus Gabriel, der selber zwischendurch immer wieder Scherze darüber macht, dass man das ja nachträglich immer alles unter einen roten Faden sieht und Stolpersteine in der Biografie dann ausgeblendet werden. Nein, schon als Vierjähriger hat er seine Oma damit überrascht, dass er plötzlich aus seinem Buch vorlas. Also war völlig klar, er möchte Philosoph werden, er möchte Deutschlands jüngster Professor werden, was auch immer. Ja, in dem Falle würde ich sagen, ist es einfach, und die reflektieren das selber ein bisschen im Gespräch, weil es ihnen auch komisch vorkommt, retrospektives Sense-Making. In meinem Fall, du hast meine Bücher angesprochen, möchte ich, dass es stimmt, wenn so darüber geredet wird. Also ich habe Redaktionslust geschrieben, mit dem Finale vor zehn Jahren der Fragestellung, wenn ich nicht mehr in den Medien erfahre, in welcher Welt mein Nachbar lebt, weil er einfach nicht nur andere Inhalte, sondern auch andere Medien konsumiert. Ich also über den Gartenzaun schaue und mich frage, was hast du auf Facebook gerade gesehen, dass das jetzt deine Lebenswelt ist? Dann ist das ein Problem, also der Fremde. So, der Fremde war also dann ausschlaggebend für, was stimmt in unseren Familien nicht, wenn wir immer hören, also in der AfD sitzen lauter Männer im Bundestag, die mit ihren eigenen Töchtern kein Wort mehr reden, weil die sich irgendwann von denen verabschiedet haben. Also wie kann Politik so sehr Familie zerstören? So, das ist Thema Altenrepublik. Ah ja, der Demografie-Dämon. Und so schließt dann natürlich das Buch über die Kinder an, weil klar, die Altenrepublik geht irgendwann schief, wenn wir an den Alten Probleme feststellen und dann, ach so, bei den Kindern geht es schon los. Also da zerrüttet schon das Verhältnis von Elementarteilchen, Familie und Staat. So, bei mir gibt es also diese rote Linie.
Ja.
Und dass wir das hier nicht vorfinden, sondern wir sagen, Momentchen mal, das Buch, das wir vor einem Jahr von ihr gelesen hatten, hatte in sich totale Inkonsistenzen. Und wenn man einen Bogenschlag von dem Buch zu dem aktuellen Buch macht, ist es einfach grotesk. Also einfach nicht zu erklären, wie das sein kann.
Ja, das wäre, als würdest du jetzt ein Buch schreiben, in dem du sagst, der Staat tut zu viel für die Familie, die Eltern sollen mal selber sehen, dass sie klarkommen.
Geh ins Fitnessstudio, dein Kind muss selber klarkommen. Ja. Also wirklich nicht zu erklären. Ulrike Herrmann ist mir hier, ihr publizistisches Schaffen ist mir nicht zu erklären.
Ja. Gut, damit verabschieden wir uns von dieser Ulrike Herrmann Ausgabe. Wer das zum Ende des Kapitalismus nochmal nachhören will, kann das ja auch tun. Der Salon ist da und wir werden uns dann diesen Monat nochmal hören zum Live-Salon. Bis dahin alles Gute.
Macht's gut.